GOOD MORNING OF THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL TO A STYLE A
QUORUM O'DONNELL. HERE
O'DONNELL HERE KILEY. SALLY
HERE SALLY HERE KALRA MCCARTY
SMITH HERE SMITH HERE WE HERE
WEBER HE. FOR WITH THAT I AM
CALLING THE THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING SOME THE AS THE S. AT.
COMMITTEE HERE OF TWO OR THE
SECRETARY JUST A SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TODAY'S HEARING EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE
FOURTEEN BILLS ON FILE TODAY
ONE OF THOSE BILLS HAS BEEN
FULL THAT BILLS AB TWELVE X.
SIXTY EIGHT THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE THAT BILL HAS
BEEN PULLED. IN ADDITION AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA WILL BE
PRESENTED BY AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY THAT WILL BE THE LAST
BILL PRESENTED. NINE BILLS ARE
ON CONSENT THOSE MEASURES ARE
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHETHER MOMENTS AB TWENTY FIFTY
TWO AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE WITHIN MOMENTS AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE. AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS. AB THREE ZERO NINE
SEVEN WE ONLY HEAR THE FOUR
REMAINING BILLS AND FILE ITEM
ORDER. BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN I
HAVE A STATEMENT TO READ
REGARDING OUR PROCESS TODAY.
THIS TO START I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE
MADE POSSIBLE OUR RETURN TO THE
CAPITAL. AND OUR ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DISSIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS IS
A LOT THAT HAS GONE ON BEHIND
THE SCENES CERTAINLY MY OWN
COMMITTEE STAFF. YOU'RE THE
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF
BUT ALSO- THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THIS BUILDING SO THANK YOU TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO. WERE OPERATING
THIS TODAY THAT ARE ARE NOT
FACES OUT IN FRONT THANK YOU- I
ALTHOUGH IT NOW SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING. REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION HELP PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS
TO THIS DSCUSSION. DUE TO THE
CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY SO AS
TO ENSURE PARTICIPATION. FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM
WE'RE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE SEVEN MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN.
OUR SIX FOOT. DISTANCING
STANDARD. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND TO SHARE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
I WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING- ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
YOUR SEATS. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME WITNESSES
MAKING USE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM HERE IN THE
CAPITAL THOSE ARE LOCATED IN
THE CAPITAL. YEAH THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE AND ALSO
ASKS. QUESTIONS OF THESE
WITNESSES THOSE HAVE BEEN
ARRANGED. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY FOR THE STREAM FROM THE
WITNESSES VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT YOU'LL SEE
ME PAUSE BECAUSE IT MEANS I'M
WAITING FOR SOMEONE. TO QUEUE
UP TO SPEAK MOST LIKELY. WE
ALSO BE USING- MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN OR
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER.
ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT IS ON THE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN I BELIEVE IT'S THE
BOTTOM. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING.
THEIR PRESENTATION YOU WANT TO
WAIT FOR YOU TO YOU FOR TO BE
CALLED ON THE OPERATE ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY LET ME RESTATE THAT.
PLACE WHEN YOU WORK. ON THE
PHONE AND YOU WISH TO OFFER
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL IT IS
NOT A TIME FOR FURTHER DEBATE.
IS A TIME FOR YOU TO OFFER
SHARE YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
SO YOU'LL STATE YOUR NAME. IF
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH ANY
SCHOOL ANY ORGANIZATION AND-
MAYBE JUST YOURSELF. YOUR
PERSONAL OPINION. THAT'S FINE-
JUST JUST JUST STATE THAT IN
STATE AGAINST YOUR NAME AND BE
DONE IF YOU KEEP GOING WE'RE
GOING TO CUT YOU OFF. THE
MODERATOR IS GOING TO CUT YOU
OFF VERY QUICKLY. AND IN ORDER
TO LET EVERYBODY PARTICIPATE WE
NEED YOU TO PLEASE. AT HER TO
THAT. YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
THERE IS ONE AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY ONLY ONLY.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'LL BE CUT OFF
LIKE THAT I'M KNOWN FOR DOING
THAT. OKAY IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. AGAIN THAT THIS
YESTERDAY WAS IN A HEARING AND
WE HEARD BACKGROUND NOISE AND
WE COULDN'T. WE COULDN'T HEAR
WHAT YOUR OPINION. SO AGAIN ALL
BACK ON A BACKGROUND NOISE HAS
TO BE ELIMINATED THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. QUE THIS INCLUDES
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SAU
DISTORTION. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY SO I WOULD ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR PATIENTS AS
WE GET CALLERS ON THE LINE.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS.
PROVIDED TESTIMONY WE YOU KNOW
WHO YOU ARE. FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU'LL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE IT WILL NEED TO PLEASE
MUTE YOURSELF. UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON THE SPEAKS OF YOUR
MAIN WITNESS AND YOU KNOW YOU
ARE IT'S BEEN ARRANGED BY THE
AUTHOR OR THE OPPOSITION- MUTE
YOUR PHONE PLEASE. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO EIGHT SEVEN AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE. TO ASSIST YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU GO THE
COMMITTEES WEBSITE YOU CAN.
ISSUE YOUR OPINION THROUGH THE
PORTAL THERE RIGHT ON THE
WEBSITE. SO THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
WE FACE WE WANT PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. SO PLEASE HELP US.
WITH ALL THAT SAID LET'S MOVE
ON OUR FIRST ITEM THAT'S FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOR
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE THAT'S BY
DOCTOR WEBER. THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IT'S A. B. EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE AGAIN THE PHONE
NUMBER- TO SHARE YOUR PAIN IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN
THE ACCESS CODE FOR YOU TO
SHARE YOUR OPINION. IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. SO
THE AUTHOR MAY- MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THEN
MEMBERS- OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF THAT'S WORKED
SO HARD AND- WITH MY STAFF I
KNOW THESE ARE DIFFICULT TIMES
AND STILL TRYING TO WORK
TOGETHER THE DISTANCES CAN BE
REALLY DIFFICULT. AND THAT
YOU'VE ALL DONE IT SO THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE. I
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY EIGHTEEN
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS THE LC UP
OF CONCENTRATION. GRANT
REPORTING. OF YOU KNOW THE I
GUESS WE'RE HERE SO IN A TWENTY
THIRTEEN EXCEPT THE STAFF. WHEN
WE DECIDED TO DO IN A DIFFERENT
THE DIFFERENT TYPE OF. FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS LET SOME OF SUB
ELIMINATING A NUMBER OF A CAB A-
AND DEVELOPING A PROCESS WHERE
WE WOULD BASICALLY FUNDING
SCHOOLS WITH THE BASE GRANT.
AND THEN DEVELOPING TO OTHER A
GRANT WHICH IS A CONSTANT IN
THE SUPPLEMENT GRANT. THIS WAS
DESIGN SPECIFICALLY. OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF THE GAP
MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE. A
FIVE. FOR ENGLISH GOING
LEARNERS INCOME FOSTER CARE AND
THOUGHT CARE. AND THE IS THE
WITH THE WITH THE- AND THE
UNDER OF ALL THE WERE INVOLVED
IN A GREAT. THAT IT TOOK A
LITTLE BIT TO IT KIDS TO WORK
WHO OF. A DEAL WITH ISSUE WITH
WITH CARE ALMOST THOSE KIND OF
THE FACT. AND SO THIS THE TIME
TO BASIC CLOSE THE CHEAP GAP.
AT THE TWO WE AGREE THAT THERE
WOULD BE ACCOUNT. SURE THAT THE
WAS GOING TO THE CHILDREN WAS
AND TEN FOR. AND THIS WAS A AN
EFFORT THAT WAS THE REALLY IN A
VERY BY. MANNER AND I
APPRECIATE THE RIVER WERE ON
WITH OFFICE TO THIS KIND. AND
WE ALL WORK AS A TWO TO MAKE
SURE THAT KNOWING THAT. THERE
WOULD BE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN WHAT I FROM. OR A LOT AREA
THAT WOULD NOT GET OF THE KIND.
OF SUPPLEMENT GRANTS THE THOSE.
EXPELLED VERY STRONG THAT
CLOSELY KEEP GAP WAS EXTRA AND
CAL. AND THAT THIS WOULD BE A
THAT WE WOULD INVESTED THOSE.
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FOR ME
BECAUSE I FELT AFTER FIVE OR
SIX YEARS THAT WE SHOULD
BASICALLY KNOW. WHAT WE'VE DONE
WITH THE MONEY AND WHAT THE NOT
THE MONEY IS GOING TO THE KIDS
THAT WAS DESIGNED FOR.
UNFORTUNATELY AND SOUGHT AFTER
LOOK AT THREE PFISTER'S CALL
WAS OPEN AND SAN DIEGO
UNFORTUNATELY THE AUDITOR A
ROOF CAME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT WE PROBABLY MOST FEARED.
THAT MOST OF THE MONEY WAS NOT
GOING INTO THE AREAS AT THAT
TIME THAT IT NEEDED TO GO. AND
AS A RESULT THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
LITTLE OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
THE MONEY WAS GOING INTO THE
PARTICULAR DISTRICTS AND FOR
THE PARTICULAR CHILDREN TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. IN
ADDITION TO THAT THEY ALSO
FOUND THAT MANY OF THE ON SPENT
DOLLARS THAT WE USE WERE
BASICALLY ROLLED OVER FROM YEAR
TO YEAR AND WOULD PUT INTO THE
BASIC GRANT AND PUT INTO THE
BASIC FUNDS OF THE DISTRICT. SO
THAT INSTEAD OF KEEPING MOST OF
MY DOLLARS FOR THE KIDS THAT
WAS DESIGNED FOR IT WAS IN TURN
IT TO THE REGULAR BUDGET OF THE
DISTRICT AND THEREFORE USED FOR
THAT. IT DISCOVERED THAT THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY. FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS BASICALLY.
IT DOING THIS FOR TWO YEARS
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT SAN
DIEGO CALL WITHIN OAKLAND HAD
ROLLED OVER THREE AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS INTO THEIR
REGULAR A BASE GRANT. RATHER
THAN USING IT FOR THE CHILDREN
THAT WERE INTENDED TO DO.THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE ABOUT
FROM THE AUDITOR WAS THAT WE DO
A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE THAT WE
DEVELOP A SYSTEM OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MONEY
THAT WAS IN IT ANOTHER BILL I.
THIRTY BUT IT ALL SAID THAT IN
EIGHTEEN FIVE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY THAT WAS FOR THE
WITH. FOR THE KIND. GRANTS FOR
THE OFFICE OF GRANT. BOTH THOSE
WOULD BE. IT COULDN'T. ONE YOU.
BE ROLLED OVER AND USED. NEW
YEAR FOR THE SAME. IT WILL
DESIGNED. THIS ISN'T. TO
PREVENT. A WHAT WE SAW A KIND
OF A PERVERSE. AT IF WILL DON'T
YOU THAT WE CAN ALL. USE IT FOR
US. AND THAT WILL BE NO
INCENTIVE THEN TO USE IT FOR
THE KID. AS IT WAS. FOR YEAR.
SO THIS BILL WAS. OF THAT YOU
THINK MUCH TODAY AND I DON'T.
BIT OF. THE DATA OF THE
TREATMENT GAP IN TERM OF. THE
GAP IS THE EXPERTS. IS GOT SOME.
GOAL DIFFERENT. IN EVERYBODY.
LANGUAGE ARE AS WELL IN MAC. OF
THERE'S A NEW FOR GREATER KIND
OF. FOR MAKING SURE THESE THAT
WE HEALTHY TO. GAP IN TELL.
THIS WAS OUR COMMITMENT DO IT.
SO THIS. THEN THE- REPORT AND
SAY BASIC. THAT YOU. BOTH
DOLLARS AND NOT YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE CHILDREN ARE INTENT. IF
IT IS ROLLED ALL. INTO THE- TO
THE MONEY. BE USED FOR THOSE
WITH. TO ARE TO. TODAY WE WITH
US JESSE WELL FORMER WHO WOULD
TEACH PLUS. AND SAM TRY. FROM
NOW. TODAY IN ORDER TO SHINE A
LIGHT ON AND AGREE JUST
LOOPHOLE. A LOOPHOLE THAT
SIPHONING OFF HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FROM
VULNERABLE STUDENTS EACH YEAR.
IN NOVEMBER AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER NOTED. THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE USING UNSPENT
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS INTENDED. TO HELP
EDUCATE ENGLISH LEARNERS.
FOSTER YOUTH AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FOR GENERAL PURPOSES.
TODAY YOU'RE LIKELY TO HEAR
FROM MANY OF OUR FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES. IN THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY. CALLING ON THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. IN A
SEVERE TO FLEXIBILITY. TO
TACKLE THE MOUNTING BUDGET
CRISIS. FLEXING SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS IS NOT
THE ANSWER. THIS FUNDING IS
ALREADY FLEXIBLE IN FACT IT CAN
BE USED IN ANY NUMBER OF WAYS
BASED ON LOCAL DISCRETION. ALL
THAT IS REQUIRED IS THAT IT'S
USED TO BENEFIT. CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS. THESE
ARE THE VERY CHILDREN WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
IMPACTED BY THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
WHO ARE FLUENT IN ENGLISH. OVER
FACED ABUSE AND TRAUMA. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PROFOUND
LEARNING LOSS THAT IS OCCURRING
RIGHT NOW. FOR THE STATE'S MAY
REP RIPPLE THROUGH THIS
GENERATION. EXACERBATING
ALREADY INTOLERABLE GAPS IN A
CHEAP. WE ARE DEEPLY SENSITIVE
TO THE FACT THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION THE STATE NOW FACES.
WE ARE TOO. THIS IS WHY WE
ORGANIZE THE COALITION LETTER
OF SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY GROUPS.
CALLING ON THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR TO PRIORITIZE KIDS AND
NOT CUT FUNDING TO SCHOOLS. WE
STAND WITH THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING EDUCATION FUNDING.
BUT WE MUST ALSO STAND
AFFORDABLE KIDS AND PROTECT
THEM IN THIS TIME OF CRISIS. IS
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON A.
B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU- WILL GO TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS ON THE PHONE WHICH IS-
JESSE WELCOME HER. MORNING CARE
DONNELLAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
OUT THE WELCOME MAT I AM A
THIRD GRADE TEACHER AT ONE
THOUSAND MANEKI EIGHT AND MY
COUNTRY CUTS THE UNIFIED. AND
EACH MONTH CALIFORNIA POLICY
ABOUT I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. NEARLY
90% OF THE STUDENTS AT MY
SCHOOL ARE IDENTIFIED AS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
ALMOST HALF FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS I KNOW FIRST HAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDITIONAL
pRESOURCES AND SUPPORT OF ADULTS
TO MEET MY STUDENTS UNIQUE. BY
TEACHERS ACROSS THE- I BEEN
KICKING. FOR THE LAST MONTHS. I
FEEL GOOD BE MY- BATES LIGHT UP
EVERY DAY DURING ONLINE CLASS
BUT IT IS NAIVE TO THINK THAT
REMOTE ITCHING WON'T HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CALL ON STUDENT
LEARNING AND WELL BEING. AND IT
IS NAIVE TO THINK THAT THE
HARDSHIP WON'T FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON THE
HIGHEST NEED STUDENT. I'M
THINKING ABOUT THOSE IN MY
CLASS WHO DIDN'T HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS INCLUDED BEGAN AND I NEW
COMERS DIDN'T WAS LOCKED IT
INCLUDES SUPPORT. BACK IN
FEBRUARY THE MOST PRESSING
MATTER IN OUR DISTRICT WAS A
NEARLY FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTED BUDGET DEFICIT. THAT
WILL ELIMINATE EDUCATOR
POSITION TO INCREASE CLASS
SIZES AMONG OTHER IN BACK. EVEN
BEFORE ADDITIONAL COVER
NINETEEN RELATED COSTS MY
DISTRICT AND OTHERS ACROSS THE
STATE ALREADY HAD TOUGH CHOICES
TO MAKE. AS A STATE AUDITOR
FOUND IN HER REPORT DISTRICT
CAN TREAT ANY UNSPENT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
FUNDS IN A GIVEN YEAR. AS BASED
ON THE FOLLOWING YEAR AND CAN
USE THEM FOR GENERAL PURPOSES.
IN THIS TIME MORE THAN EVER WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE GRANT
MONEY INTENDED FOR
DISADVANTAGED GROUPS OF
STUDENTS. ACTUALLY BENEFIT
THEM. THE CURRENT GOAL BOOK
YOUR DID A COVER NINETEEN ARE
AFFECTING ALL SCHOOLS AND ALL
STUDENTS. BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
HIGHEST NEED STUDENTS WILL BE
DEBT FORTUNATELY IMPACT AT. THE
STATE HAS THE RIGHT THE BILL
NEEDS TO DO A QUE. TO AND THAT.
BOB HOPE DID IN ARE NOT FURTHER
TO MANAGEMENT WILL BE OPEN.
I'LL BE A FACT AND THE L. EIGHT
HAVE. THE BILL AND HOW THEY
CHOOSE TO THE TIME. WHAT DID
NOT BE FLEXIBLE AT THESE FUNDS.
THE STATE THEY WERE. FOR I URGE
THE LEAD. PASSED AB EIGHTEEN. I
TO ME THAT. INTENDED FOR
DISADVANTAGED. ARE USED TO
IMPROVE. AS FOR THEM. STUDENTS
CAN'T AFFORD FOR TO WAIT. THANK
YOU. THANK I APPRECIATE THAT
ALL WITNESSES ARE STAYING UNDER
TO MINUTES WHICH- IS A- IS THE
REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE- OUR-
THE OPPOSITION AND WE'LL HEAR.
A LITTLE ESKIMO. NO. A RUN
PHONE FOR OPPOSITION GENERAL OF.
OKAY REGARD OKAY SO. CANCER A
RIDDLE OUT TO PUBLIC UPPORT NO.
I'VE IT'S MY FULL WE GO TO THE
PHONE. AND WE'RE GONNA HEAR
THOSE NEW MEMBERS THE PUBLIC.
THAT WISH TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THIS IS A- WHERE YOU STATE YOUR-
A PHILLY. AND ON THE BILL. PLAY
TO THE PHONE PLEASE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FINAL BUT ARMY INSIDE THERE WAS
ONE THAT WAS THE STRAP. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL QUEUING UP AT THIS
POINT IN THEIR NICKNAME
AFFILIATIONS BEING TAKEN THANK
YOU SIR.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A CARD
FOR THE LINED UP JENNIFER OR
WHAT UP FROM EE THE VOICE. THE
LINE IS NOW OPEN. JENNIFER
WATER ON BEHALF OF AT BOYS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE OTHERS AS
WELL BUSH STILL TAKING THEIR
NAMES I APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY.
OKAY AND WE DO HAVE A COMING
FROM THE- ASHLEY- TAUGHT
FIGHTER OF. REVOLUTION AT THIS
POINT. ACTUALLY WHAT REVOLUTION
SUPPORT.
WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FROM SAM DASHER OF LA COUNTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SAM DASH
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. YEAH
BUT NOT SURE WHAT THAT THE ON
OFF THE DECISION ON THE PART OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. OKAY THAT
WE DO HAVE KEVIN PRIMER TO.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. KEVIN
PROPER YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
I'M SORRY NINETEEN SEVENTY
SOMETHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BASED IN A BLACK BUT LET THE
PATRIOT MISSILE. AND WE DO HAVE
A CURRENT FROM KIMBERLY BARNES.
THE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
APPARENTLY SHE JUST DROPPED I
APOLOGIZE. TO RESPOND AS YOUR
LINE TO OPEN. OKAY WE HAVE A
COMMON FOR THE LINE OF. CARLOS
NOT CUT OVERLY. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CARLOS. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CARLOS MACHADO WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. AND WE
DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM CARLOS
MARQUEZ. FORGET ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS IS
THAT THE ASIAN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE. AND WE TO A COMMENT FROM
MARTHA TIAS. MISTY IS YOUR EYES
SO OPEN. MARK SAID SERRA GOES
THE DS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
AND WE DO HAVE A COVER FOR THE
LINE OF JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
FOR THE LINE OF MISS AARON.
EMPTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THERE AND HAPPY LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU I WILL NOT GO
TO THE AUDIENCE ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE AND
SUPPORT. PLEASE COME FOR DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIAN RIVAS ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WESTON SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEN
NO OTHERS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE AUDIENCE AND SUPPORT
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION. OUR
FIRST MEMBER OF THE OPPOSITION-
WILL BE LET'S WITH SQL- AND SHE
IS ON THE PHONE. FROM THE
MOMENT HERE TO AMUSE HER.
OKAY
MA'AM YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HELLO MY. I APOLOGIZE IT'S- I
THINK.
OKAY MA'AM YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY. I'M NOT A PROBLEM. YES
THANK YOU ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
ARE JUST NOT THAT BEFORE THE
HEALTH CRISIS WE HAD A CONCERN
POSITION ON THE BILL AND HAVE
HAD AND HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
OF OFFICE IN THE SPONSORED
GIVEN THE DIRE FISCAL CONDITION
THAT THE STATE FINDS ITSELF IN
WE UNDERSTAND THE LA AS WILL
NEED MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGETARY SHORTFALL
AND PARTY FRIEDMAN WE NOW HAVE
ENOUGH POSTPOSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
OF GO TO JEFF BACA HE IS ALSO
ON THE PHONE JEFF AKA. YOU
MISTER CHAIR ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME. YES. JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY ARE
PLEDGES THAT EVERY STUDENT WILL
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
ACADEMICALLY AND SOCIALLY
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE THE
WORKFORCE AND CIVIC
RESPONSIBILITY OUR MISSION IS
TO ENSURE THAT PICKED UP OF ALL.
AND TO ACHIEVE EQUITABLE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS IN OUR
SCHOOL WE WERE NOT INTENDING TO
OPPOSE AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE
WHEN IT WAS INTRODUCED. HOWEVER
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
DISTRICTS ARE FACING OF THE
RESULT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS WE REGRETFULLY MUST
OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE WE'VE
ABILITY BUT LEAVE IT WILL MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT. TO ACHIEVE
OUR PLEDGE ADMISSION. AS A
RESULT OF THE CURRENT CRISIS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FACING
REDUCTION SEVEN MAGNITUDE EVEN
GREATER THAN THAT WHICH
STANDARD AND THE FIRST FOUR
YEARS OF THE RECESSION THAT
BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
WHEN A CUMULATIVE TOTAL OF ONE
TIENEN ONGOING REDUCTIONS THE
COR K. TWELVE FUNDING EXCEEDED
HUNDRED THAT EXCEEDED THIRTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO
PRIORITIZE AND PRESERVE
PROGRAMS FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
AT RISK STUDENTS AND TO BETTER
GET THE LOTS OF LEARNING THAT
THE CRISIS THAT ALREADY CAUGHT.
BUT IT IS A CERTAINTY THAT ALL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THE.
FORTHCOMING RECESSION. WE HAVE
ALL THE RICH IN THE FOR MAY
WEBER AND THANK HER FOR BEING A
CHAMPION FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. WE REMAIN COMMITTED
TO A DISCUSSION WITH THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT COMPREHENSIVE
CHANGES TO THE LP ABOUT. THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE MORE THAN ONE
MILLION STUDENTS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES WHO CURRENTLY
RECEIVE NO BENEFIT I'M
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING.
HOWEVER UNDER THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE IT'S NOT A
SOLUTION THAT WILL BENEFIT
THOSE STUDENTS AND THE SHORT
FOR THE LONG TERM. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR KNOW
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE FOR OPPOSITION TO THE
PHONE. IF YOU HAVE A COVER TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM
KIMBERLY BURNS YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI KIMBERLY BARNES FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
AND WE DO HAVE A CURRENT FOR
THE LINE OF MICHELLE UNDERWOOD
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU THE MORNING MICHELLE
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. THERE ARE TWO MORE
COMMENTS TO BE BETA. WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF.
TIFFANY PROTEGER PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GET ME BOTH WE AND I OPPOSE ANY
ACCOUNTING. THANK YOU. AND
WE'RE WAITING ONE MORE COMMENT
FROM THE LINE UP BROOK LOPEZ
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISS
LOPEZ YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
OKAY HI MY NAME BURKE LOPEZ
NINE FROM MONTEREY COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS POINT GREAT THANK YOU GO
TO THE AUDIENCE ANY PERSONS IN
THE AUDIENCE WISH TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. SAYING OPPOSITION IN
THE AUDIENCE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEN OF QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS READY TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS. BEEN MOVED TO A SECOND
IT- YOU MAY CLOSE. I WANT TO
THANK- AS I SAID THOSE WHO HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS BILL-
AS WE BRING IT FORWARD I
WOULDN'T WANT TO THINK THAT MY
OUT THE COLLEAGUES WHO ARE ON
THE LINE WHO EVEN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AND I UNDERSTAND.
THEIR CURRENT THEIR CONCERN IN
THERE AND WE KNOW THAT THERE
WILL BE CHALLENGES ALWAYS WITH
REGARDS TO ECONOMICS BUT THAT
THE VERY STILL IS THERE THAT
THE POOR ALWAYS PAY MORE. AND
WE KNOW THAT OUR KIDS ARE
SUFFERING TREMENDOUSLY FROM
THIS AND EVEN IN GOOD TIMES OUR
DISTRICT DID NOT CHOOSE TO PUT
TO PRIORITIZE THESE CHILDREN IN
THE FUNDING. AND IN FACT WHEN
WE WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THIS AND I WAS
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN THE LC FF
CHANGE. THE DISTRICT SAID VERY
CLEARLY PLEASE PLEASE PUT
RESTRICTIONS ON THIS MONEY
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHEN WE GET
INTO THE POLITICAL PROCESS AND
WITH DEALING WITH TEACHERS
UNIONS AND NEGOTIATIONS AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THE POOR
KIDS AT THE BOTTOM WILL PAY.
THE LEAST INFLUENTIAL IN MOST
DISTRICTS AND THEREFORE THIS
MONEY WOULD NOT EFFORT WILL
NEVER GET TO THEM SO EVEN IN
GOOD TIMES FOR THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS THESE KIDS HAVE NOT
BENEFITED FROM THESE DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT HELD A
DISTRICTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR USING
THE MONEY AS IT SHOULD BE HAVE
BEEN SPENT. WE COULD NOT AFFORD
TO ONCE AGAIN FEEL THESE KIDS
AGAIN EVEN IN THIS PANDEMIC
THEY ARE SUFFERING THE MOST
WHETHER IT'S THE BUSINESSES
WITH THEIR LIVING CONDITIONS
WITH IS THE HEALTH WE KNOW THAT
THEY THAT THE NUMBER OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINOS A DYING
MORE THAN ANYONE ELSE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE LEAST PAID JOB AT
THE WORKING OF BOTH DURING THIS
VIRUS. I KIDS ARE FAILING ARE
LOSING EDUCATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALREADY BEHIND OF WEED
I'VE ALREADY DEVELOPED THE
COMMITTEE TO START THINKING
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO. TO
BASICALLY UP. MINIMIZE AMOUNT
OF LOS THE KIDS ARE BLUE. GET
THE RESOURCE WILL HAVE OVER THE
NET SIX WEEKS. IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE LOSING. WE CANNOT FAIL THEM
AGAIN BY SIMPLY SAYING WELL
IT'S A PANDEMIC. AND WE NEED TO
LET THE DISTRICT DECIDE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO. THEY HAVE
DONE THAT BEFORE AND FOR THEM
TO SAY WELL WILL PROBABLY HELP
THEM OUT THIS TIME WE WILL TRY
TO PRIORITIZE THEM. THAT IS NOT
TRUE. WE MUST PRIORITIZE THEM.
AND FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE BILL
FOR EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU- THE MS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THE MOTION IS. TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. HI
THE DONALD HI KILEY. KILEY I'D
DALLY SALLY I KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY PARTY AYE SMITH I WEBER
BUT WHATEVER I THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR OUR OWN NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR BY MISTER
NAZARIAN. AS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX
FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO UTILIZE A
BEST VALUE BID EVALUATION AND
SELECTION PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS IN EXCESS OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS PROCESS
HAS ALLOWED LA U. S. THE TO
LOOK AT BETTERS BASED ON SAFETY
FINANCIAL CONDITION INSURANCE
COVERAGE CRIMES AND MISCONDUCT
FUNDING SETTLEMENTS AND
JUDGMENTS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SELECTION OF A BITTER BASED
SOLELY ON PRICE MAY RESULT IN
PROJECT DELAYS AND COST
OVERRUNS AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
ALLOWS FOR MORE OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA FOR SELECTING BIDDERS
WHICH IS SHOWN TO YIELD
POSITIVE BENEFITS IN SELECTING
QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS AND
COMPETITIVE PRICES. THIS BILL
SIMPLY EXTENDS L. U. S. THESE
AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE THE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT METHOD FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS ALONG THE
STATE MORE TIME TO EVALUATE THE
BENEFITS OF THE MODEL AS
CURRENTLY NO OPPOSITION- AND I
BELIEVE WITH ME IS- OLGA SHILOH
FROM. THE US THE- THANK YOU
MISTER IZZARD FIRST BEFORE WE
DO THAT WHAT I DO WANT TO JUST
SHARE AGAIN. IS THAT FOR AB
EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR- YOU CAN CALL
IN WITH YOUR COMMENTS- AND THAT
NUMBER AGAIN IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN I'LL REPEAT THAT ONE MORE
TIME. TO PARTICIPATE ON THIS
ITEM. AB NINETEEN. EIGHTY ONE-
EIGHT SET THE CALLING NUMBERS.
877-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. THE AUTHOR-
THANK YOU RESENTING THE BILL
WILL NOT GO TO THE SUPPORT- WE
HAVE- OLDER SHALLOW BELIEVE. ON
THE LINE. IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS- DISTANCE
OVER SHILOH WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE THE SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
WHICH WILL EXTEND THE FUNDS THE
AUTHORIZATION TO UTILIZE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT MESSAGE FOR
BETA VALUATION AND SELECTION ON
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
ABOUT ONE MILLION DOLLARS AS A
PILOT PROGRAM UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN BEST VALUE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO WORK WORKING
CONTRACTORS SEVEN CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY FOR APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS THE PROJECT SPANNED
THIRTEEN SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND
BENEFIT ESTIMATE OF EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS
ALTHOUGH BACK BODY CONSCIOUS
WERE SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
OVERALL NUMBER OF CONTRACT
SECURE TWENTY SIXTEEN AND LA
UNIFIED THE DOLLAR VALUE
COMPRISE THE MORE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MORE THAN 90% OF ALL
YOUR CONSTRUCTION CAUGHT. THE
PROJECT THE BENEFIT OF THE
INITIAL PILOT PROGRAM INCLUDED
REDUCE CONTRACT DELAYS HE WERE
CHANGE ORDER AND LET PLAYING
FROM CONTRACTORS BOLDLY. REDUCE
CAUGHT. IF SENATE ARE REALIZED
BY. YOU WITH THE I YOUR PART
PRO. THE DAY BEST OUT SO AND
INSIDE THE QUALIFY. NUMBER JUST.
WILL CONTROL. I COUNT. BUDGET
SCHEDULE PROVIDES MORE
SOPHISTICATED EXTRA AND TRUCKS
RELATION WITH LA YOU THREE
TEMAS STRONG PROJECT FOR. WHAT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STATE
LOCAL FUNDS SPENT ON
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT OF
CONSTRUCTION A LATE YOUR- IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO REDUCE
STRESS AND MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCY
FORTY THREE POINT WHERE POLICE
THE FUNDS ARE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
I TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT QUEUING. WE DO HAVE A
COVERED FOR THE LINE JEREMY
SMITH. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOURNEYS NEXT YEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WHAT. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS POINT SEE NO
FOR THE SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
WILL GO TO THE AUDIENCE ANY.
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE WHICH
TO. SHARE THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. OUR THEY ARE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL ON THE
PHONE. ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ON THE PHONE. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THERE IS ONE COMMON QUEUING.
AND WE DO HAVE A KEVIN FOR THE
LINE A FURRY- A RECALL PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I OPPOSE. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS. THANK
YOU KNOW I KNOW FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE ANY
OPPOSITION PRESENT IN THE ROOM
HEARING ROOM. ST OPPOSITION IN
THE IN THE HEARING ROOM DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. REMOVED AND
SECOND IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- WITH THAT- WELL ASKS
THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE I FORGOT TO
MENTION THAT I. HAPPY TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENT AS WELL COMMITTEE
OF THE SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE THANK IN THE CHAIR
THANK YOU AND THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. WITH THAT- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. NOT LOADING CANNOT
VOTING VALLEY. COUNTY NOT
VOTING KALRA FIVE KALRA AYE
MCCARTY. RT ICEMAN SMITH I
WEBER WHENEVER I. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT MR IS
HEARING THE BUILDING IS OUT
THANK YOU WITH. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO- FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT'S A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THE PHONE NUMBER
GOING TO CALL IN A COMMENT ON
THIS BILL IS 877-692-8957 IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN AGAIN
TO PARTICIPATE ON THIS BILL THE
PHONE NUMBERS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR. THREE SEVEN. AND
OF IS NOT WHO. WHO'S BILLS IS.
WHERE IS A- IT SHOULD BE HERE.
I MEAN I WE'VE ALL BEEN PATIENT
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY NOW WE NEED
TO WAIT ON PEOPLE IN THE
CAPITAL. YEAH CAN. I HOPE A
STAFF HEAR ME COMMON RIGHT NOW.
THE CHARGES TO BE TO BE CONTACT
HIS OFFICE MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THE STATE HE WAS ON HIS WAY YOU
KNOW. HE DID IT IN ALRP.
TALKING ABOUT. YEAH THE BILL
I'M SORRY HI I KNOW I KNOW I
DON'T. I'D WAS GONNA WEIGH
ABOUT ONE. DO NEW DO WE NEED TO
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WHEN WE DO THAT. SECOND
ASSEMBLY THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED ANY
TO READ OFF. DO I READ OFFICE
THANK YOU. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
AS FOLLOWS AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB TWENTY FIFTY
TO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY ONE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CAN AB THIRTY
NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS. AND
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL
HI O'DONNELL I HIGHLY. SALLY
DALY AYE KALRA. HOWEVER I AM A
PARTY. HI MY PARTY I'VE MET
SMITH I WEBER NUMBER NINE SIX
DOLLARS SIX THE IN SECULAR SIX
VOTES IT IS OUT MR- CUNNINGHAM
HAS BEEN NICE ENOUGH TO SHOW UP
TODAY SO WELCOME MISTER
CUNNINGHAM- WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO- IT A B. NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE I'M
GONNA REPEAT THE PHONE NUMBER
ONE TIME IF YOU ONE MORE TIME
IF YOU WISH TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS BILL- THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CALL IN IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE TO AGAIN
SHARE YOUR OPINION ON THIS BILL
THIS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN IS FILE NUMBER FIVE
A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE FOR MY TARDINESS THAT
WITH MY OFFICE WITHOUT MY MASK.
GET IT. SO I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND A
STAFF OF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AB NINETY TWO WOULD
ALLOW TEACHER CREDENTIAL
CANDIDATES TO USE QUALIFYING
COURSEWORK TO SATISFY THE
STATE'S MANDATED BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENTS OR BSR. THE
BIZARRE ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ARE PROFICIENT IN
READING WRITING AND MATHEMATICS
BEFORE ENTERING A CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WITH THE
CANCELLATION AND DELAY OF THE
SEA BEST TEST DO TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. MANY CREDENTIAL
CANCER LEFT WITHOUT A WAY TO
SATISFY THE BSR CURRENTLY.
CONSEQUENTLY THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ENTER THE TEACHING
CREDENTIAL PROGRAM WHICH MIGHT
EXACERBATE THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
IN CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THE TEST CANCELLATION.
BY ALLOWING CANDIDATES FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS TO USE
QUALIFYING COLLEGE COURSEWORK
TO SATISFY THE BSR AND ENTERED
THE CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS THEY
MUST EARN AB OR BETTER IN THE
QUALIFYING COURSEWORK. WE ARE.
IN THE MIDST OF AN
UNPRECEDENTED TEACHER SHORTAGE
IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S BEING MADE
WORSE BY THE CANCELLATION
TESTED COVERT WE NEED SOME
FLEXIBILITY THIS IS OF
PARTICULAR CONCERN IN THE AREA
OF ELEMENTARY SCHOOL EDUCATION
WHERE THE SEA BEST HAS. SHOWN
TO BE SOMEWHAT OF AN
IMPEDIMENT. TO RECRUITING
QUALIFIED QUALITY TEACHERS. CBS
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS NEVER
STUDIED IT'S EFFICACY THERE IS
NO STUDY SHOWING IT CORRELATES
WITH CLASSROOM TEACHER
PERFORMANCE. THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT PASSED IN THE C.
BEST LEADS TO BETTER TEACHING
PERFORMANCE. IN FACT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE
TO THE CONTRARY THAT'S THE BEST
ACTUALLY HAS NO CORRELATION TO
FUTURE PERFORMANCE. I AM NOT AN
ANTI STANDARDIZED TESTS GUY SO
IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC THAT I'M
HERE. IN A BRIEF Y. PRESENT THE
SPELL. CAN I PULL DOWN. SO OUT.
THIS IS GREAT THANK YOU YEAH
BUT I WANT TO PASS OUT. I'VE
NEVER WORN WITH THESE MASS IT
IS HARD AS HECK TO BREATHE
TALKING THE STATE LIFE LIKE
THAT THANK YOU. SO YOU KNOW FOR
INSTANCE THE ELSE AT THE LAW
SCHOOL ADMISSION TEST THAT
THINK IT'S ACTUALLY. QUITE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SKILLS
YOU NEED TO- QUOTE THINK LIKE A
LAWYER I THINK THE M. CAT IS A
PRETTY GOOD REPRESENTATION
SKILLS. AND KNOWLEDGE BASE THAT
YOU NEED TO BE A DOCTOR. I THE
QUESTION I THINK. ALL THAT FOR
THE SEA BASS IS WHETHER IT
CORRELATES. TO TEACHING
PERFORMANCE THAT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY EVIDENCE THAT IT
DOES. THIS WOULD ENHANCE
FLEXIBILITY AND- IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THE C.
BEST. IS CALIBRATED TO ATTEMPT
TO TEST BASIC PROFICIENCIES IN
READING WRITING MATHEMATICS
ELEVENTH GRADE LEVEL BUT WORK
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW COLLEGE
COURSEWORK WHICH BY DEFINITION
IS HIGHER THAN ELEVENTH GRADE
LEVEL TO COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSEWORK. IF YOU'RE IN A BEER
BETTER- TO MEET THE VSR. I
THINK IT'S A WORTHY. A BILL
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION.
AND THUS ENDS MY PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
SEE THE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE-
I GUESS WE DON'T HAVE ANY SEE
ANY SUPPORT ON THE PHONE I
APOLOGIZE. YEAH I'M SORRY WE DO.
IT'S HARD WHERE ISABEL- GARCIA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION A DOWN THE VIDEO
THE VIDEO ROOM I APOLOGIZE I
WAS ON THE RUN BILL. FIFTY GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM IF THIS BILL
GARCIA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
URGING YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE CTA
COSPONSORED NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
THIS IMPORTANT BILL MAINTAINS
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR BASIC
SKILLS MEASUREMENT IN READING
WRITING AND MATHEMATICS FOR
TEACHER CANDIDATES BUT ALLOWS
PERSPECTIVE TEACHERS TO MIX AND
MATCH QUALIFYING COURSEWORK
WITH OTHER EXISTING OPTIONS TO
MEET THE BASIC SKILLS
REQUIREMENT. CTA BELIEVES
THERE'S A BELL WILL INCENTIVIZE
DIVERS TALENTED INDIVIDUALS TO
ENTER THE TEACHING PROFESSION
WITH THESE ADDITIONAL NINE TEST
BASED OPTIONS TO MEET THE BASIC
SKILLS REQUIREMENTS WHILE
MAINTAINING HIGH STANDARDS FOR
THE FASHION. SEE BELIEVES
TEACHER CANDIDATE SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE
PROFICIENCY IN BASIC SKILLS IN
MULTIPLE WAYS INCLUDING
QUALIFYING COURSEWORK. THE BILL
GOES FURTHER TO ENSURE HIGH
STANDARDS BY REQUIRING A BI OR
BETTER IN COURTS WORK TO
DEMONSTRATE BASIC SKILLS BEYOND
THE EXISTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE ALLOWING FOR A C. OR BETTER
IN COURTS WORK TO DEMONSTRATE
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY.
CALIFORNIA'SCHRONIC TEACHER
SHORTAGES COMPOUNDED WITH THE
COVERT NINETEEN TESTING CENTER
CLOSURES THE IMPACT ON THE
TEACHER PIPELINE IS SEVERE IN
THIS BILL IS NEEDED TO BROADEN
THE ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS FOR
INTERESTED INDIVIDUALS TO ENTER
THE TEACHING PROFESSION TO MEET
THE BASIC SKILLS REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT INCURRING MORE COST FOR
MORE DELAYS. TO MEET OUR
STUDENTS NEED. CITY I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BELL IN COMMENCE THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL AND
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR FIVE
VOTE TO PASS A THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW THOSE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. HE
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS A ONE ZERO. IT'S TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT TO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AND WHEN SPEAKING.
YOUR NAME PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. AND YOUR AFFILIATION
THANK YOU. WE HAVE. COMMENT
FROM MISTER CARLOS MARQUEZ
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARLETT MARKET
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
THE TECHNICIAN SUPPORT. AND WE
ALSO HAVE A COME IN FOR THE
LINE OF MISSION AARON EIGHT
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ERIN
AFTER YOU WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ANOTHER COMEDY IN SUPPORT
FROM MISS SASHA HORWITZ. MR
THIS IS SUCH OVER WITH THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING- THE COMMISSION
HAS NOT TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT I'D LIKE TO SAY
WE WORK WITH THE OFTEN STAFF
AND AMENDMENTS WHICH THEY'VE
ACCEPTED. THANK YOU. PLEASE
FORGIVE ME. BUT WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF THIS.
BRAND RAP. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT FROM JEFF OF AMERICA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK. THE
LINE IS NOW OPEN. IT'S ABOUT
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU JEFF BACA
REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. IN OTHERS ARE KILLING
IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
INFORMATION BE TAKEN HERE. YEAH
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF THE COMMON
FOR THE LINE OF MRS IN CHANDLER
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN MASTER'S DEGREE.
AND I WANTED TO. SUBSTITUTE
TEACHING AND I WISH. I HAD. THE
CASF AND I SEEM. TO ME THAT IF
YOU HAVE A MASTER'S DEGREE YOU
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST
NEED TO. KNOW AND SUPPORT.
SHOULD SEE AND ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL YEAH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT'S ALL WE
NEED THANK YOU MUCH. YEAH WE DO
HAVE ONE FOR THEIR KEVIN
QUEUING UP HERE.
HEY THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS AT THIS
POINT I APOLOGIZE THANK YOU THE
GO TO THE OPPOSITION NOW. OR IS
THAT IS THERE ANY IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT IN THE IN THE IN I'M
SORRY IN THE ROOM. IF YOU CAN
COME UP THE MICROPHONE. JUST
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF YOU'RE WITHIN A
GROUP AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL IN THIS CASE.
IN JUST PLEASE DON'T TOUCH
MICROPHONE. HI. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRONG. MY
AFFILIATION THANK YOU AS I'M
MARRIED TO A CREDENTIALED
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER.AND I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT. THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. SO SINCE
I TRAVEL TO THE CAPITAL AND I
HAVE ANOTHER THIRTY SECONDS NO
OF THOSE ONLY TIME FOR ITS YOU
STATE YOUR POSITION YOUR YOUR
YOUR NAME FILIATION A POSITION
ON THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
YOU ALWAYS RIGHT INTO THE
COMMITTEE TO THE PUT IN THE
ANALYSIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. IS THERE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT WITH A WE HAVE ONE MORE.
HELLO MY NAME'S KATHERINE MY
PRIDE AND I WORK FOR DAVIS
JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BOTH I WITH THAT NO OTHER
SUPPORT IN THE ON IT THERE'S A
ONE MORE LOOKS LIKE THERE'S ONE
MORE COMPORT LEASE. IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER SPORT AFTER THIS
PLEASE COAT PLEASE SPACE
YOURSELF COME PORTER RAISE YOUR
HAND I GUESS IT'S BEST WAY TO.
OKAY DID I UNDERSTAND. SOMEBODY
SAY THAT. THE TESTS THAT YOU'VE
BEEN REQUIRING. IS NOT A
PREDICTOR WHATSOEVER WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT AND WHAT'S RIGHT
RIGHT NOW WE YOU DO SEE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IMPOSITION ON
THE BILL ON I'M SORRY MY NAME'S
HEATHER WONDER AND NO
AFFILIATION OTHER THAN A PARENT
FORMER TEACHER FOR TEN YEARS-
AND YOU SUPPORT THE BILL I
DON'T KNOW I'M ASKING. FOR
CLARIFICATION ON THAT POINT
WHAT WE CAN DO IS WE GET YOU
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTIONS AFTER
THE HEARING WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE CONTACT YOU IF YOU
WANT TO HAND HER AYEAR YOUR
INFORMATION OF THE SERGEANT
OVER THERE HOW CAN WE CAN WE
CAN COMMUNICATE. OKAY YEAH THAT
INDEED THERE IS NO CORRELATION
BETWEEN MAKE IT TAKE YOU RIGHT
NOW BUT RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
THE TIME FOR THAT. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL- WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION AND I BELIEVE
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE IS-
BREAD INTO THE EGG FROM- IT.
INVOICES ON THE PHONE IF I'M
CORRECT. AND WE WENT IN. THERE
WE GOT I MEAN I'M IN. UP ON
BEHALF OF AT VOICE WERE OPPOSED
TO AB NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WHICH
WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THE
BAR FOR TEACHER CANDIDATES TO
BE DEMONSTRATED MINIMUM
PROFICIENCY IN BASIC READING
WRITING AND MATHEMATICS SKILLS
OBJECTIVE DEMONSTRATION OF
MINIMUM PROFICIENCY IN BASIC
SKILLS PROVIDES A MINIMUM
GUARANTEED TO PARENTS. THAT
TEACHERS ARE COMPETENT AND
BASIC SKILLS BY ALLOWING
TEACHER CANDIDATES TO
SUBSTITUTE COURSEWORK FOR THE
FEEDBACK REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL
SAYS THAT ALL COLLEGE BE GRADES
AT OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE NATION
ARE EQUIVALENT WHICH WE KNOW IS
NOT THE CASE CALIFORNIA ALREADY
ALLOWS EXEMPTIONS FROM THE SEA
BASS FOR EXAMPLE. CANDIDATES
CAN SATISFY SATISFY THE BASIC
SKILLS REQUIREMENT BY ATTAINING
SPECIFIED SCHOOLS ON THE SAT
ACT. AN A. P. EXAMS AMONG
OTHERS THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT
THOSE ARE ALL OBJECTIVISTS
JASMINE'S RATHER THAN GRADES
THAT VARY FROM ONE COLLEGE TO
THE NEXT THE CBS NOT PLACE AN
UNREASONABLE BURDEN ON TEACHER
CANDIDATES IN MATH OFTEN CITED
AS A DIFFICULT SUBJECT. THE
HIGHEST COMMON CORE STANDARD OF
STAFF TO THE SEVENTH GRADE
LEVEL CONTENT REGULAR OF PRE
ALGEBRA HELLO MATH ONE.
NINETEEN IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN ITS
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
SCHOOLS WILL LIKELY HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
OTHER CHANGES TOO MANY MORE
TEACHERS TO ADDRESS THE NEED.
SINCE WE ALREADY HAVE A TEACHER
SHORTAGE IT'S LIKE WE WILL HAVE
MORE LONG TERM STEPS TO WITH
THE MANAGED. FORTUNATELY
IMPACTED THE BATCHES MEANINGFUL
FILTER SUBS. ACCORDING TO SEE
DATA THE FIRST TIME PASSAGE
RATE FOR. AN AMERICAN PERMIT IN
IN THE SAN AND THE KING THAT
RATED FROM THE EIGHTY. WHILE
THE PASSAGE FOR CAN GOING
THROUGH TEACHER PREP PROGRAM IS
BETWEEN NINETY FIVE AND A
HUNDRED. WITHOUT MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WILL
BE AT EVEN GREATER RISK OF
BEING TAUGHT BY SOMEONE THAT
ISN'T COMPETENT AND BASIC
SKILLS. LAST I'LL POINT OUT
THAT BEEN FOR THE CPC PROVIDED
A DEFERRAL OF UP TO ONE YEAR
FOR THE C. BEST TO COVER
NINETEEN. AND TESTING
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE IN
VARIOUS LOCATIONS WITH MORE
COMING UP MEMBERS THIS IS
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITY WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A
LET'S GO TO OTHERS ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION YOU CAN STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE OTHERS ON THE PHONE. IN
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS A ONE ZERO AND ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT
HERE.
WE DO HAVE A TALENT FOR
THE LINE OF GLORIA- PENA.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YES YEAH AND AYE
OPPOSED SAY THE.
NINE NINE
ZERO. WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
NEXT COMMON NAME THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OUR. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
QUOTE OF THE COMMENT FROM THE
LINE OF DECISION CORTES. YOU
CAN YES SICKLE TEST NOT
CREATION AND I'LL POST BILL TWO
NINE NINE ALL AND THESE BILLS
WELL. THANK YOU. AWAITING THE
NEXT COMMENT. LEAVE A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE OF- SHE A SHE NOT
ONLY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH AND
SHEEN OLSON CALLING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY I'M A HOMESCHOOL PARENT
AND I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. FROM THE. AB ONE MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN YOU CALL IN YOUR YOUR
YOUR TESTIFYING IN THE CORRECT
BILL. JUST FOR PEOPLE ARE
CALLING IN ABOUT EITHER WHERE
IS A ITEM DO WE HAVE OTHERS ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. WE TO
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A COMMENT
FOR THE LINE OF. A ROW CO COULD
TIERRAS. IT LANDED ON IT THAT
YOUR LIGHT IS NO OPEN. YES GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'M A PARENT
NIGHT OPPOSE THE DEATH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMMENT TO. THEN WE TO
HAVE A COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF
MISS ROSIE. LOUISIANA PLEASE.
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE ARE I'M A
MOM AND- I HAVE TWO KIDS THAT
GO TO A CHARTER SCHOOL IN AYE
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS SIR. I THANK YOU. I'LL
NEVER GET BACK ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM SEEN OPPOSITION THE
ROOM WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
TO EMOTION FIRST. SOME OF IT'S
MY MOVED AND ALL SECOND. BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED SO QUESTION
TERM FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM I SUPPORT THE BILL I
MADE THE MOTION THE AND AS YOU
OUTLINED THE BILL YOU TALKED
ABOUT HOW NOW IT'S RELATED TO
CULTIVATE NINETEEN OF THIS
THREE YEAR PEACE BUT WE WHEN
YOU INTRODUCED IT IT WAS MUCH
MORE- MUCH MORE BROAD CORRECT
SO IT'S NARROWED AND YOU'VE
YOU'VE TAILORED IT TO THE SPINE
AT NUMBER OF YEARS. SO DO YOU
THINK THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THAT. OUT OUTSTANDING ISSUES
AND CONCERNS. YEAH THAT WAS.
THAT WAS THE COMMITTEES IDEA I
THINK IT WAS A GOOD ONE WHEN I
INTRODUCED THE BILL WAS- IT DID
NOT HAVE A THREE YEAR SUNSET
AND NOW WE'VE ADDED THE THREE
OR SUNSET AND I THINK- THAT'S
VALUABLE BECAUSE WE CAN SORT OF
STUDY AND ASSESS HOW IT'S
WORKING COUPLE YEARS OUT. AND
LOOK AT WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
EXTENDED AFTER THAT AND I
THINK- TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
CO THAT RELATIONSHIP THAT YOU
KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM
ALL THESE PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
TAKE THIS TEST THIS YEAR AND
THEREFORE THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET INTO THEIR CREDENTIALING
PRO AND WE ALREADY HAVE A
LOOMING SHORTAGE IN THE FACT.
THAT THE SO I MEAN. WE HAVE TO
SOMETHING OUT OF. THE PEOPLE
THE- DON'T HAVE THE OP. TO TAKE
THIS TEST AND GET GET INTO
TEACHING- AND THEN I WANTED TO
DRESS IF. THERE IF IT'S OKAY OF
THE CHAIR MAYBE SOME OF THE-
ARGUMENTS. MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION. BUT YEAH I WELL I
WANT YOU THAT IN YOUR CLOSEST
TO MAKE SURE THERE AREN'T ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I. MR KILEY.
I'M NOT QUITE ALIGNED WITH-
WHAT TIMES TO CUNNINGHAM IS
TRYING TO DO HERE BACK I'D LOVE
NOTHING MORE THAN TO SEE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING REFORM
ACROSS THE WHOLE RANGE OF
PROFESSIONS IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A THE MOST ONEROUS-
BURDENS- TO ADD TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA OF ANY STATE ARE
ROUTINELY RATED THAT WAY THAT
THE REASON I'M GONNA UP STAYING
FOR TODAY- IS I THINK THERE ARE
SOME DISTINCT CONSIDERATIONS
WHEN IT COMES TO ADD. AS OF THE
EXISTENCE OF A OF TENURE LAWS
WHICH ARE ACTUALLY- AND
NATIONAL OUT WIRE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- FOR THE WAY THEY
ARE STRUCTURED- WHICH MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO DO MEANINGFUL
EVALUATION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FOLKS- ONCE
THEY'RE IN THE PROFESSION SO-
I'M I YEAH I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW MISTER CUNNINGHAM MAKES A
COMPELLING CASE THAT THE SEA
BASS IS NOT A WELL ALIGNED. TO
EFFECTIVE TEACHING PRACTICE BUT
I'D LIKE TO SEE AN EFFORT TO
REFORM IT DONE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH PUTTING IN A BETTER
ASSESSMENT AS WELL AS WITH
REFORMING OUR TENURE LAWS IN
CREATING A SOMETHING THAT I AM
STRIPPING IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
WHICH IS ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS
FOR FOLKS WITH ASSET TECHNICAL
BACKGROUND ENTERED TEACHING
PROFESSION PRINCIPLE STUDENTS
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH AT
THE CUSTOMARY ROUTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOTE CAL. K. TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS DON'T
GET TENURE. THEY GET ON
PROBATION OR STATUS. AWARE THAT
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
DOCTOR. YEAH I WANTED TO- AND I
HAVE YOU KNOW SOME DIFFICULTY
WITH THIS TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
ONLY BECAUSE- YOU KNOW I THINK
CLEARLY THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND BEING ABLE
HAVING TO SUSPEND TESTING IS
REALLY HAD AN ISSUE IN A
CONCERN. NOT SURE IF IT'S A
THREE YEAR CONCERN BUT IT IS A
CONCERN TEMPORARILY- AND IT'S
NOT THAT DIFFICULT THE TASK
BECAUSE YOU COULD JUST THE
ACTUAL TESTING BIGGER ROOMS AND
SPARE PEOPLE OUT AND SO. USING
USING EVERYBODY SEEMS WILL USE
COLD IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING THEY'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO DO- AND- AND SOMETIMES IT
MATCHES AND SOMETIMES IT
DOESN'T AND IN THIS IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE. I'M NOT SURE
IF IT MATCHES BECAUSE THERE ARE
WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN TEST FOR
CBS AND THEY HAVE LOTS AND LOTS
OF TIPS IF YOU SPREAD PEOPLE
OUT IT'S NOT LIKE THEY HAVE TO
INTERACT WITH INDIVIDUALS. THEY
CAN SPREAD THE MOP THE
CANDIDATE VARIOUS KINDS OF
WAYS. MY CONCERN CONTINUES TO
BE IS I'M NOT SURE IT AS IS
POINTED OUT THAT THIS IS THE
THIS IS ANY TIME THE BEST WAY
TO ACTUALLY SORT OF FIVE PEOPLE
QUALIFIED TO TEACH IN OTHER
WORDS WHAT THE TEST IS GOING TO
DO IT. BOB THESE THE YOU KNOW
THE STUDENTS WERE TAKING SEA
BASS RIGHT NOW OUR STUDENTS WHO
HAVE GONE THROUGH COLLEGE. THAT
THEIR BACKS IS THE GREEK AND I
ASKED TO PERFORM ELEVENTH GRADE
LEVEL. IN THOSE WHO AND I'VE
BEEN MUCH OF. ONCE AGAIN FOR
THIS TO BE. CAN'T PAY. CBS
WHICH ELEVEN. TEACH OF THE
PROFICIENCY. AND I FIND IT
DIFFICULT TO BELIEVE THAT THAT
I WOULD WANT THEM TO GOING TO
TEACH ENGLISH MAP TO MY KIDS.
WHEN THEY CAN'T PASS AT ELEVEN
GRADING THEY'VE SPENT THE LAST.
TWELVE YEARS OF HIGH SCHOOL AT
LEAST FOUR OF NOT MORE AND
COLLEGE AND STILL HAVE HAVE
ELEVEN GREAT PROFICIENCY. IN
ENGLISH AND MATH. SO I HAD LOTS
OF FRIENDS WHO TOLD YOU KNOW
CBS AS RACIST AS THIS IS THAT
SO FORTH AND SO ON I'VE HEARD.
ALL OF THOSE STORIES. AND I
HAVE TO REMIND MY STUDENTS THAT
EVEN IF I BELIEVE CBS WAS RACES
THEY GOT A EUROPEAN EDUCATION
WHEN THEY WENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. OR SEE
ISSUE. SO IT'S NOT LIKE I SPENT
THE WHOLE TIME- DISCUSSING
BLACK LANGUAGE IN BLACK PEOPLE
OR MEXICAN TO WHATEVER. THEY
SPEND A VESTIGE. OF IT. THE
ACADEMIC. STUDYING EUROPEAN
CULTURE AND LANGUAGE MATH. SO
YOU KNOW. IT'S A DIFFICULT
THING FOR ME BECAUSE I DO THINK
THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO
SURVIVE PEOPLE. I'M NOT SURE
IF- IF THIS ISN'T. AN
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO SUBSTITUTE
WITH A CLASSROOM TESTS. AND
HAVING SEEN STUDENTS. AS
HAVING. SPENT FORTY YEARS OF
UNIVERSITY. AND THINGS STUDENTS
WHO ACTUALLY END UP IN MY CLASS
OF SENIORS. AFTER HAVING THREE
YEARS OF. SUPPOSEDLY SUCCESSFUL.
ACADEMIC YOUR COLLEGE STILL
ABLE. DO TO BE. WRITE AT A
LEVEL FOR FIFTY I CAN.
APPROPRIATE FOR SENIOR. IT
DOESN'T ME A LOT OF HALF A
DOZEN A THAT SOMETIMES STUDENTS
TO A HATED THAT MY COLLEAGUE TO
TEACH SO. I KNOW AND THEN I
KNOW THIS IS A- SUPPOSED VICTIM
FOR. BUT I WOULD HATE AS MOST
THINGS DO WE PUT THINGS IN FOR
THREE YEARS AND THEN WE- REMOVE
THE SUNSET. AND IT BECOMES A
THING AND WE NEVER DISCUSSED
THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF HOW DO WE
ENGAGE. IN CERTIFICATION OF
TEACHERS AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF YOUR CONCERNS TOO. HOW DO
WE- DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT'S
BETTER AND I'VE SEEN SOME
STATES ARE NOW GRAPPLING WITH
IT AND DOING MORE IN TERMS OF.
APPRENTICESHIPS AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON AND- AND I'LL DIRECT
EVALUATION OF NEW TEACHERS IN
THE CLASSROOM AND DOING A WHOLE
LOT OF WONDERFUL THINGS AND
THEY- TALKED ABOUT IT HERE BUT
THEY DO IN A LOT OF IT IN
MICHIGAN. AND WE HAVE.
CERTIFIED TO BE TEACHERS
SUPPORT THEM WHILE THEY'RE
THERE AND HAVE SOME SECURITY
THAT WE CHOSE THE MOST FOLKS
WERE READY FOR SCHOOL SO. I GET
CONCERNED WHEN I SEE THE COLD
WOULD BECOME THE ANSWER TO
EVERYBODY'S PROBLEM. AND IT IS
A PROBLEM AND IT IS A CHALLENGE
OF BUT IT CAN'T BE THE ANSWER
TO ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
AFRAID TO ADDRESS. THAT'S MY
CONCERN. THANK YOU- NO FIXING
NO FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE-
COMMITTEE. YOU MAY CLOSE.
EFFICIENTLY PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF DR WEBBER ALL
AS TO THE COVERT ISSUE- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE TESTS
WERE CANCELLED RIGHT THAT FOR
THIS YEAR IN THE SPRING AT THAT
AS OF MAY FIRST CERTAIN TESTING
SITES WILL BE RE OPENED BUT
THERE'S SOME TROUBLE WITH THE
ROLL OUT OF THAT AND SO THERE'S
AND IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
TEST IS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
ADMINISTERED THIS YEAR REALLY
ANYWHERE- SO. THAT'S THE IMPACT
AND THEN- FROM COVERED NINETEEN
THE THREE YEAR THING I MEAN
THAT I GET THIS KIND OF SOME
TIME TO GET THE CREDENTIALING
COMMISSION TO. THE STUDY THAT'S
FOR REAL. WHETHER THE YOU.
SERVES A PURPOSE. AND WHETHER
THAT PURPOSE AND WHETHER
THERE'S VALUE IN IT THAT'S
WORTH THE- YOU KNOW THE
IMPEDIMENT. BECAUSE IT IS A
PART OF SOME PEOPLE GETTING THE
PROFESSIONAL COST MONEY TO TAKE
IT. AND AGAIN THERE'S THEY PUT
IT INTO LAW IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
AND NOBODY'S EVER STUDY WHETHER
IT WORKS. BY WORK I MEAN
WHETHER THERE IS A- WHETHER IT
IS A PREDICTOR OF TEACHING
SUCCESS. AND WHERE THE REAL
PINCH POINT JUST BE. COMPLETELY
CANDID I THINK THE REAL PINCH
POINT. ARE YOU HAVE FOLKS THAT
HAVE TROUBLE WITH ELEVENTH
GRADE MATH ON A STANDARDIZED-TESTS AND- THEY MAY BE FINE IF
NOT THEY MAY. NOT BE OR BETTER.
YET OR NAY ON THE COLLEGE LEVEL
MATH COURSE WORK THE COUNTS. SO
THEY THEY CAN DO IT IN THE
CLASSROOM SETTING THEY THEY'VE
SHOWN THAT NAY PROVEN THAT THEY
CAN DO THAT. BUT THE GO TAKE A
STANDARDIZED TEST AND SEE BEST.
AND THEY AND THEY HAVE TROUBLE
WITH THAT. AND THAT KEEPS THEM
FROM GOING IN TEACHING LIKE
FIRST GRADE OR SECOND GRADE OR
THIRD GRADE WHERE THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE TO TEACH. ELEVENTH
GRADE MATH. THE BE TEACHING
COUNTING AND STICKS AND BUNDLES
AND- ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
YOU KNOW. MY YOUNGEST KIDS ARE
LEARNING TO DO. YOU KNOW THAT
OUR NEW- CURRICULUM THAT WE
HAVE NOW MY DAUGHTER IS. DOING
HOME SCHOOLING. AND THE
TEACHERS MORE THAN WHAT WOULD
NORMALLY HAPPEN TO ME I THANK
GOD SHE'S A POSITION AND
UNDERSTANDS IT. BUT IT REALLY
GETS TO THE LOGIC OF MASS MUCH
DEEPER UNDERSTAND THE MAP AND
THAT'S A BIG CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW. IS THAT FOLKS CAN DO THE
BASICS OF ONE TWO THREE AND ADD
AND SUBTRACT. BUT WHEN YOU TALK
TALKING ABOUT MATH AT A AT A
DEEPER LEVEL IN TERMS OF THE
LOGIC OF MATH. IF YOU'RE NOT
GOOD AT MATH YOU ALMOST GO FILL
THOSE KIDS IN IN IN THOSE
GRADES AND SO SHE'S TEACHING
HER KINDERGARTENERS AND HER. A
SECOND GRADER MATH AND SHE SAID
IT'S MUCH DEEPER THAN SHE HAD
THOUGHT BEFORE TONIGHT HE WAS A
MATH AND SCIENCE MAJOR. US SO
ACTIVEBUT WHAT I DON'T YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THE TEST
HAS NOT BEEN DONE DOES THIS
BILL REQUIRED THEM TO. THE
COULD I'VE- INTENTION WOULD BE
TO WORK WITH THE CREDENTIALING
COMMISSION. THE MENTOR NO NO.
NO MANDATE THATTHEY DO IT OKAY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM.
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND THE
MAN IN THE BILL. THAT'S
SOMETHING WE COULD ADD. TO IT
I'D LIKE TO. SEE THAT BUT I
THINK IF TO HAVE ME RIGHT WHERE
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD. MAKE IT
HARDER. BUT IT'S PROBABLY WOULD
YEAH RIGHT. TRYING TO. DO ABOUT
HELL OKAY AND YOU KNOW MY PALM
ON ROUND FOUR OF MY FOURTH GET
TEACH MATH I HAVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN PHYSICS AND THE WAY
MASCOTS COMPLETELY DIFFERENT NO
WAY ALERT AND SO WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO PLAY CATCH UP ON THAT
I JUST DON'T THINK THE SEA BASS
IS CALLED OUT I THINK IT OUT
DATED WELL THE COMMON CORE.
YEAH MATHIS. THAN KNOWING HOW
TO TEACH IT. I DON'T. DOUBT IT
BUT WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU UP. THE
I'LL LET YOU READ THE MOTION
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAD THAT MOVED YEAH WE HAVE
REMOVED IN SECONDS O'DONNELL
BY. MADONNA I KILEY. KILEY NOT
HURTING TALLY. COUNTY NOT
COMING KALRA. RIGHT CONRAD I
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH NOT VOTING WEBER. FIVE
MEMBER WEBER I. BUT THOSE FOUR
VOTED IS OUT IT IS OUT THANK
YOU THEY WERE NOW GING TO MOVE
TO. AB TWENTY NINE NINETY AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY THIS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN IF YOU
WISH TO CALL IN ON AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY. REPEAT THE PHONE
NUMBER. BY THE NUMBER IS.
1-877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THE PHONE
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL IS MISS
CRISTINA GARCIA SHE IS NOT
PRESENT TO SAY SO IN LIEU OF
HER PRESENTING THAT BILL WILL
BE MISTER MCCARTY- MAY GO AHEAD
AND. EIGHTY TWENTY NINE NINETY
WHEN YOU ARE READY. AND THAT'S
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
OF COURSE I
AM NOT ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
BUT PRESENTING FOR HER THIS
MORNING I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB. TWENTY NINE NINETY-
FIRST I WANTED TO THANK THAT
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE. AND
STREAMLINING THE INTENT OF THIS
AND WILL WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON PAGES SEVEN AND
EIGHT TO THE ANALYSIS SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AS AMENDED THIS
MEASURE PRESENTS TO BE A
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S CURRENT LACK OF
OVERSIGHT. OF NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS OR HOME
SCHOOL CHARTERS. AND FRANKLY
ADDRESSES THE FOR A FLAGRANT
MISUSE OF PUBLIC FUNDS TO
VENDORS FOR EDUCATIONAL
RICHMOND ACTIVITIES WE READ
ABOUT THESE IN THE NEWS WERE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS- PAY FOR
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES NOT TO GO
LEARN ABOUT MOTHER NATURE BUT
GO TO DISNEYLAND SEE WORLD AND
HAVE- INTERACTIVE ACTIVITIES AT
THEMES PARK SO THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT TAX PAYER OVERSIGHT. AND
EQUITY- CURRENTLY FAMILIES AND
ROLLED IN NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVE STATE
FUNDING TO OPERATE THEIR
PROGRAMS THESE FIVE RANGE.
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED PER PEOPLE OF STATE TAX
DOLLARS WITH NO GUIDANCE OR
STANDARDS AND HOW THESE MONIES
CAN BE SPENT. AS A WHAT THE
RECRUIT SOME OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS OFFER AND- TO
PERSPECTIVE FAMILIES TO SHARE
THE FUNDS WITH ERRANT'S FOREIGN
CONNECT LIVE REALLY PUT ON.
CRAIG'S THIS AND OTHER WEB
BASED UP TO DISNEYLAND SEA
WORLD IN THE TO. UP THE CIRCUIT
COMPANY IS A ARE IN THE- THAT
THAT OFFER THESE ARE. SEVENTIES
STUDENTS AND HOME CHARTER
SCHOOL WORKS. CHARTER SCHOOL IS
AREA I WILL A DOES NOT HAVE A
LOT OF DATA IT'S A FEW YEARS
AGO THE MOST RECENT WAS JUST
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND- ONLY. A.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY HOME
SCHOOLING IS SOMETHING THAT WE
RESPECT AND WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN CURRENTLY
DO THAT BUT- TAXPAYER DOLLARS
INVOLVED MAKE SURE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE. A PROPER OVERSIGHT
AND A LACK OF OVERSIGHT RAISES
QUESTIONS OF EQUITY. AND THE
BEST USE OF OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS EVERY STUDENT MATTERS
ZIP CODES HAVE AN EQUAL
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY AN
APPROPRIATE EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES TO
SUPPORT THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS-
BUT WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THIS IS
WITHIN REASON. OF THIS MEASURE
PRESENTS A REASONABLE SALUTE
AND TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S
CURRENT LACK OF OVERSIGHT OF
HOME SCHOOL CHARTERS. AND THE
FLAGRANT MISUSE PUBLIC STORE
EDUCATIONAL. FOR EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES- THIS
BILL NO WAY WOULD RESTRICT
OPPORTUNITIES FREHLEY ACE TO
ENTER INTO VENDOR CONTRACTS
FOR- SANCTIONED AND FRANKLY
APPROPRIATE EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES JUST HAVE
SOME MORE OVERSIGHT CLARITY-
THE BILL WOULD SUPPORT THE
QUALITY OF THE VENDOR SERVICES
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
USED APPROPRIATELY FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT BENEFIT OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AS AMENDED THE MEASURE
PROVIDE QUALITY IS MEASURE
FAMILIES. THAT ARE PROVIDED
PUBLIC FUNDS FOR THESE
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES THROUGH
HOME SCHOOL CHARTER SCHOOLS
AGAIN THE FALLOUT FROM KOBE
NINETEEN MAKES THIS BILL EVEN
MORE RELEVANT AND NECESSARY WE
WILL LIKELY SEE AN INCREASE
ENROLLMENT OF NON CLASSROOM
BASS SETTINGS BECAUSE OF THE
PUBLIC CRISIS WERE FIXING AND
MAKES THIS MEASURE BEFORE US
EVEN MORE SO RELEVANT I KNOW I
KNOW THAT THE IS NOT TODAY BUT
BUT SHE BUT IT TO THE STE WORK
HARD THE OFFICE. THEY COULD
COME TO HUNDRED MEANING NINE A
SHE TO J. THAT WORK HERE FOR A
BIT LATE AND ME TO TODAY
REMOTELY STRESSED BROWN WITH
THE FEDERAL. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. WE THINK
WE'LL GO TO. MAY ONE IS IN
SUPPORT MISTER BROWN. EYES
WHICH IS DOWN IN THE ROW THE
VIDEO ROOM. THANK YOU CHAIRED
MA'AM MY NAME TRISTEN BROWN OF
THE CAL BETTER OF T. AND WE
KNOW MORE THAN EVER PARENTS
HELP. OUR OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
HEARING WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THE STORIES OF
PARENTS STRUGGLING TO COPE WITH
THE PANDEMIC. HATSUMI SAY
RENEWED AWARENESS NOW OF THE
VALUE THAT PUBLIC EDUCATORS
PROVIDE STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. EVERYWHERE NOW PARENTS
ARE STRUGGLING TO WALK DAYS IN
THE SHOES OF A TEACHER OR
CLASSIFIED CUSTODIAN FOOD
SERVICE WORKER CLERICAL YOU
NAME IT. AN ATTEMPT TO GUIDE
THEIR CHILDREN THROUGH THE
PATHWAYS OF DISTANCE LEARNING.
WE KNOW HOW HARD IT IS BUT FOR
MANY THIS TEMPORARY ISSUE WAS A
LIFESTYLE THAT PARENTS HAVE
CHOSEN FOR THEIR CHILDREN THE
JEWS THE ROLL UP THEIR SLEEVES
AND HEAVILY HOME SCHOOLED IT'S
TO PROVIDE THE REGULAR NEEDED
FOR SIX. LETTER IN LIFE.
HOWEVER SEPARATE PATHS WERE
MEANT IT'S ALSO AND JOE TO A IN
NON CLASS BASED INSTRUCTION PRO.
ESPECIALLY BY SCHOOLS PRODUCTS
IN A STUDY PROGRAM INTO FULL
FLEDGED TO COVER EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. HERE'S CERTAINLY A
PLACE FOR INDEPENDENT LEARNING
PROGRAM FOR SOME TYPES OF
STUDENTS WITHIN OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. THE ISSUE
COMES WHEN PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
SPENT WITHOUT ANY OVERSIGHT AND
WHAT MAY BE CALLED EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES BUT
CERTAINLY STUDENTS ON
INDEPENDENT STUDY TRACK SHOULD
REAP THE BENEFITS OF
TRADITIONAL FIELD TRIPS TO
PLACES. LIKE ART PERFORMANCES
OF MUSEUMS CENTERS OF SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY FOR EXAMPLE IS
OUR SHARED HISTORY. HOWEVER
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY SAMPLES
HIGHLIGHTED RECENT NEWS REPORTS
A SHELLAC OBJECTION BY SOME
ALLOWED BY THE LACK OF
OVERSIGHT FROM OURSELVES- I
WON'T REPEAT WHAT MISTER
MCCARTY IS JUST A LIST WITH
YOU. AND WHILE THE SAFETY NOT
ON THE- TO WHICH THE OTHER ONE
WE DO HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPORT
OVERSIGHT SHARED RESOURCES. NO
NEED TO PREACH TO ALL OF YOU
ABOUT FUNDING LEVELS OF OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM.
IMPENDING CRISIS WILL PROVIDE.
THANK MORE THAN EVER THE
OVERSIGHT. SO THAT EVERY DOLLAR
FOR THE STUDENTS AT A- AS THAT
IS A KEY. TO OUR- CAN CORRECT
FRAMEWORK. SO WE'D LIKE TO
LEGISLATIVE MAXIM THAT PUBLIC
AGENCIES AT THE STORE THE
PUBLIC DOLLARS. NOT INDIVIDUAL
PARENTS NOT PRIVATE CORPORATE
BOARDS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS NOT
EVEN ALL OF OUR MEMBERS THAT
ARE TEACHERS THROUGHOUT THE
THOUSANDS OF CLASSROOMS THAT
EXIST. AND SO TO THAT END WE
SUPPORT THE REASON A MEMBER TO
THIS BILL THAT BRING PARITY
AMONG TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CHARTERS. SAFEGUARD
THE FIRST AMENDMENT BY
PROTECTING OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS
FROM PRIVATE RELIGIOUS SCHOOLS.
AND RESPECT THE LOCAL CONTROL.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES TO
DETERMINE WHAT OUR PROGRAM
EDUCATIONAL ENRICHMENT PROGRAM
BENDER. TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC
CONTRACTING IN THE USE OF
PUBLIC FUNDS. WELL FLEXIBILITY
pEDUCATION IS ONE THING.
FLEXIBILITY ON THE QUALITY OF
SPENDING PUBLIC DOLLARS IS A
WHOLE OTHER. SO WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE NINETY. RIGHT YOU. I
BELIEVE THERE'S ONLY ONE MAIN
WITNESS IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
THERE- SO WHY DON'T WE GO TO-
WILL- SUPPORT FOR THE BILL ON
THE PHONE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
ON THE PHONE YOU STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IF THERE IS
ONE IN YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILLONLY IF YOU DO ANYMORE
THAT IT WILL BE CUT OFF TO GET
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. ON THE PHONE
PLEASE. WE HAVE ACOMMENT FROM
THE LINE OF- CARLOS MARQUIS
HERE THE LINE IS NOW OPEN. I
APOLOGIZE THEM SPEAKING
OPPOSITION SO YOU CAN COME BACK
TO ME. OKAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK OR COMMENT ON THIS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE ARE
SEVERAL QUEUING UP. OKAY BUT WE
DO HAVE A CAR FOR THE LINE OF.
I POLITICIAN. GLORIA PENA. A
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN MYSKINA
APOLOGIZE. YEAH HI- I OPPOSE AB
TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I AM A GRANDMA. THANK YOU.
AND WE TO ATONE FOR THE LINE UP
MISS BETH DO BOY. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE. YES HELLO I'M
CALLING ABOUT THIS BILL AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION TO IT AS
ORIGINALLY WRITTEN I DON'T KNOW
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
HOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE
OF. MISTER RICHARD. PORTMAN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE.
YES GOOD MORNING NOT A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE THANK YOU
FOR OUR FOR OUR GIVE ME
OPPORTUNITY CONTENT FIVE RIGHT
NOT POSITION TO THE PROPOSED
BILL EIGHTY TWO DIDN'T TWO NINE
NINE ZERO- THANK YOU WHERE
THANK YOU. AND WE TO HAVE A
QUICK COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF
FIRE HONDA HOT. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES I AM WITH REGARDS TO AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO I OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM EVE. SAID RICK
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU THAT YOU HAD A SAN BRUNO
CALIFORNIA HOME SCHOOLING
MOTHER TO OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU. AND
WE O HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE
LINE OF TIFFANY. JOHNSON YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU CAN
GET. MANY OF THE JOHNSON FROM
BURBANK CALIFORNIA FORMER
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
POLITICAL APPOINTEE I'M
APPROACH AB T. NINE NINE ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF.
ABRAHAM YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS ABRAHAM I'M- AND
I AM CALLING TO OPPOSE EIGHT
THREE TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. OKAY WE TELL TELEPHONE
LINE OF SHE. I APOLOGIZE IT
JUST JUMPED FROM MY SEAT- OIL
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DIANE
AND THE FOUNDER AND POLITICAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN AND
I'M CALLING IN TO OPPOSE EIGHTY
TWO NINE NINE. THANK YOU. THEN
WE DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR OUR
MILITARY COMING FROM THE LINE
OF- MICHELLE DO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. YES THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS MICHELLE NEWMAN I'M
CALLING FROM BRING A CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AS A HOME SCHOOL MOM AND
ALSO. FOR THE ORGANIZATION-
LINES TO PROTECT CHILDREN AND
WE OPPOSED THE BILL AB Q. NINE
NINE NOW. THANK YOU. EN ROUTE
TO A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF
CARISSA- SHAKEN NOW. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS CORRECT
THE SHACK I AM CALLING FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO. HEY WE
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE LINE OF-
DESTROYED PAUL. AIRLINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI ELECTED TO A BALL AYE
OPPOSED AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
AND WE TELL THE CURRENT FOR THE
LINE OF THIS AGENDA JENNA
CABANA YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU I'M MY NAME'S JANET
COMPAGNIA I'M CALLING FROM TO
MACULA I'M A CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENT MY OPPOSED AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE A QUESTION OF A COVER FROM
LINE OF C. BOIL YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. WELL YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. WE HAVE A QUESTION FROM-
ACOSTA MIND OF CARLOS MARQUEZ
YOUR LINE IS STILL OPEN. CARLA
PARK AT THE MAP THE VISION IN
EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO. CAN WE TELL
CURRENT FRONT TIFFANY- BILLION
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS TIFFANY MILAN
AND THE PARENT WITH TWENTY
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN THE HOMES
WILL TRY TO SYSTEM AND ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NEW TELL THE
TOPICAL ALLIANCE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE. NINETY
THANK YOU. CAN WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM A SHAME IN
PATTERSON. HI YES GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS SHOW ME ON
PATTERSON- FRESNO CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOLING PARENTS AND I
UPHOLD AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT
WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FOR THE
LINE OF DELI. TING CANNOT SORRY
MA'AM YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE ON NOW
YOU CAN CANCEL REGISTERED NURSE
AND PARENTS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY WE
DON'T TAKE AWAY GREAT
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. AND WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FOR A LINE OF
THIS STACY MONTILLA HERE ON
LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES THANK YOU
STATE EIGHT MONTHS BUT I AM A
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER AND CPA
MEMBER. I'D WRONGLY UPLOADS THE
BILL AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
HAVE A COMMENT
MAGNUS YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER MAGNUS
AND I'M CALLING FROM SANTA
MARIA AND THE MOTHER OF SIX AND
I OPPOSE AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE
OF. ELENA SCHNEIDER. I'M SORRY
THE RANGE SCREEN THERE'S SO
MANY QUESTIONS HERE I APOLOGIZE.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN THE
SCHNEIDER I APOLOGIZE. THE
STATE ARE GOING UP THE OPEN.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A QUICK
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF. HELLO
NON. IN QUIET DESPAIR THE HERE
THERE'S.
HEY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THIS- ALLANA AND CLAY. MY NAME
IS A LOTTA IN A GUY I AM AN
ADVOCATE FOR STUDENTS WITH
DYSLEXIA AND OTHER LEARNING
DIFFERENCES I'M A PARENT OF
THREE STUDENTS IN A CHARTER
HOME SCHOOL AND COUNTRY BUT THE
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE. AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO. THANK YOU. OKAY
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM
THE LINE OF NAY SO XO YOUNG. HE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS A LOT THE YOUNG I'M A HOME
SCHOOL MOTHER OF THREE IN THE
AREA OF THE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE. EIGHTY TWO NINE NINE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE A COUPON
COUNTY LINE OF JESSICA
GABRIELLA HERE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA COVER
THAT AYALA I REPRESENT THE
ORGANIZATION THE PROTECTION OF
THE EDUCATIONAL RIGHT THE KIDS
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL WHICH WILL
UNINTENTIONALLY AFFECT INNER
CITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EN ROUTE TO THE
COVEN FROM SHE HADN'T. MATTHEWS
WITH THE HERE. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME SHANNON
MATTHEWS- FROM HIS CALIFORNIA
HOME SCHOOL MOM AT THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. AND
WE TO HAVE A QUICK OF CONCORD
LIGHT OF MISS KRISTEN A
SHEPHERD YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME. CALIFORNIA I. OKAY
AND WE TO HAVE COMMENT FROM THE
LINE OF THIS TIFFANY-
POETICALLY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ASSEMBLY HOME FOR PARENT
AND I ALSO OPPOSE SB. TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. CAN WE TELL A COMMON
FOR THE LINE OF BRIAN SMITH.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRIAN SMITH TO LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA HAVE A
CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS WERE
GOING TO DO IT. AND I OPPOSE AB.
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE A CALL COMING FROM THE
LINE OF MACKENZIE LARSON. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE CAN BE
LARSON I'M A FORMER HOME
SCHOOLER AT CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND AYE OPPOSED.
EIGHTY TWO NINE NINE ZERO. THEN
WE DO HAVE A COMMON FOR THE
LINE OF JESSICA. HELLO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I AM A
CANTERLOT ONGOING MOTHER
CONFOUNDING AND CO FOUNDER OF
ETHNIC AND POLITICAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN AND
I'M GOING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. YEAH WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF
CHEN L. LAW. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI THIS IS JANELLE LARA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT A. M.
THANK YOU ROSE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU FOR
SURE. OKAY AND WE A LINE OF AMY
DE UM. LEAVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THIS IS AMY MCCAMLY
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. MERE MOMENTS HERE
THERE ARE SEVERAL STILL. OKAY A
TO HAVE A COMMON FOR THE LINE-
CHRISTINE LANDERS SHE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING. THE
LATTER I'M CALLING FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I'M A HOMESCHOOL
MOM AND A SPECIAL NEEDS MOTHER
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOL THE
BILL WOULD DO NOTHING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU RETURN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE TO THE
COMMENT FROM A LINE OF GENE.
ARE TAKE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JEANNIE TAKE FROM
YORBA LINDA CALIFORNIA I'M A
MOM OF TWO IN PUBLIC SCHOOL AND
MY THIRD IS ABOUT TO ENTER A
CHARTER SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE AB
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE
OF CHIEF KELLY XIN BECAUSE KEEP
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS KELLY CASKEY I AM CALLING
FROM PACIFIC GROVE IN MONTEREY
COUNTY I AM A HOME SCHOOLING
PARENT AS OF LAST FALL IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. AND WE TO A COMMON
FOR THE LINE OF BRIAN YOUNG.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BRIAN YOUNG FROM
MARIETTA CALIFORNIA I'M A
HOMESCHOOLING DAD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF CHILE-
NJ AND- ADRIAN COLE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I JULIE ANDROGENIC GIRL
AND I OPPOSE AB TWO NINE NINE
ZERO THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF A
PATH TO VOICE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS NO EASY BOB
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I'M
A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD HOME SCHOOL
AND I'VE NEVER BEEN TO
DISNEYLAND OR DISNEY WORLD. AND
I THINK YOU DE OPPOSITION ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE STILL HAVE SEVERAL TO.
WE HAVE A CONFERENCE LINE-
JANELLE CHANGE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JANET
CHIANG AN APPARENT THREE
CHILDREN ONE ATTENDED PRIVATE
SCHOOL WHEN ATTENDED SCHOOL NOT
A LOT AND I OUT BE ENTRENCHED
WONDERFUL. AND EIGHTY TO NINETY
THANK YOU. OKAY AND WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM LINE- EMMA
BEATEN BENDER- PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I AM NOT
BEATING THAN THAT YOUR SITE
CHARTER HOME SCHOOL MOM OF
TWELVE YEARS AND REPRESENTING
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS OF
CIRCLE OF HOME SCHOOLERS GROUP
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU. HEY WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF.
CIRCLE ADMIN HERE LINE IS NOW.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LARISSA GLADDEN I'M LIKE
ARTICLE CARE AND EDUCATORS FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY OPPOSES QUICKLY
MISGUIDED AND UNNECESSARY
BUILDING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK HEY WE DO HAVE A COVERED
FROM THE LINE OF. THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AND I. AM I
AM A- MY AUNT- WELL. HEY WE
STILL HAVE SEVERAL COMMENTS
HERE. LINING UP. HEY WE TO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM SPEAKER THOMAS
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS TO MAKE A COMMENT THAT I
REPRESENT ACADEMY OF CREATIVE
EDUCATION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY.
THANK YOU. JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
HAVE JESSICA. PAN HELLO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HOW. I'LL.
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM A
TREE WILLIAMS. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. I APOLOGIZE IT'S AT THE
SCREEN JUMPED TO AN OPEN. OKAY
MILLION ON. GO AHEAD PLEASE I
THINK MY NAME IS AVERY WILLIAMS
I'M CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AS A TAX PAYER AND
HOMESCHOOLING MOM OF FOUR I'D
THAT DEFINITIVELY OPPOSE THE
BILL TWO NINE NINE DIRECT.
THANK YOU. OKAY AND WE NEED TO
THE- COMMENT FOR LINE IT. SAND
TEN AT CENTROLEGAL PLEASE GO
HEAD I APOLOGIZE FOR YOUR NAME.
HI MY NAME IS GETTING SAN
ANGELO AND I'M COMPOUND LOOK
BEFORE COUNTY AND THE VENDOR
DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATOR FOR A
LOCAL CHARTER EVERYTHING OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND VENDORS WHO DO
NOT OFFER THEME PARK SERVICES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT. TWO
NINE NINE HOW. WE DO HAVE A
COLORFUL LINE OF MELANIE-
BURKHOLDER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MELANIE BURKHOLDER AND IT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
AND SEVENTY SIX DISTRICT AND
AYE OPPOSED AB TWO NINE NINE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK
YOU CAN A BETTER DIRECTION.
WITH THAT THEY HAVE. YEAH NEW
YOU DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER FOR
THAT THEY PERCEIVE MODERATOR
PLEASE. YES ABSOLUTELY I'M JUST
TRAINING WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR SOME NAMES HERE AND I'M
TRYING TO FIND THE SUPPLIES
THAT WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN HERE
SO I APOLOGIZE SIR TO SPEND.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A CONFERENCE
LINE A MYSTICAL COLLEGE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY IT THE
CALL COLLINS AND FROM THANK YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA. CO PARENT AND
I AM COSTA DEL. OKAY WE DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR A LINE OF
MISSING MEANWHILE TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS AMY WILDE FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHEN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. OKAY. AND WE TO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR THE LINE OF-
PRUDENT SHEA JONES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS BROWN CHECK
JONES ON BEHALF LEARN FOR LIFE
I IAN MACKAYE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY. OKAY NEARLY TO HAVE A
QUESTION FROM THE LINE OF. ZERO
PARA CURE LINE IS NOW OPEN. YOU
ARE A LA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
THEN WE- YEAH FURTHER COMMENT
HERE JUST BEAR WITH ME OKAY WE
DO HAVE A QUESTION FROM THE
LINE OF SHARE A- ABOUT A YEAR
LINE NOW OPEN. BISHARA FOLLOW
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. CAMERA
RELEASED HERE. WHAT. WHAT'S
COMING UP WITH. WHAT DID YOU
CALL ME FOR BEING. OKAY WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION THIS BEAR WITH
ME MY. WE DO HAVE A CLIENT LINE
FROM THE ACCOUNT ONLINE- JEFF-
JULIE IS A PIZZA. RIGHT YOU'RE
SO OPEN BUT THE JURY THE
PRODUCT CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS
OF TWELVE YEARS I WOULD
STRONGLY OPPOSE L. A. A. B. TWO.
NINE NINE ZERO. BECAUSE I'M
CRIME IN OPPOSITION ACTOR. WE
NOW THE TIMING AND A HALF
MINUTES. OKAY SO HERE I DON'T
KNOW I THOUGHT A HEADER LINE
RELEASED HERE. NINE NINE ZERO.
EIGHT ACT IF THE HOME SCHOOLING
BILL. BUT MODE NEED I'M TRYING
TO OF LIGHT ON HAVE HER HE TO
SCREW WITH ME. WELL JUST BEAR
WITH ME HERE THANK YOU SIR. WE
ARE YOU GONNA BE OUT SOMETHING.
SB OFTENTIMES. ALRIGHT SO I'M
NOT SURE THAT LINE IS COMMITTED
A METER OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION FROM THE LINE OF.
THANK HEY WE DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE LINE OF SUMMER CHESSIE
SPARE WITH ME HERE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MID SUMMER JESSE. HI MY
NAME IS SUMMER JESSE I'VE BEEN
A HOME SCHOOLING TURN FOR EIGHT
YEARS MY CHILDREN HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO DISNEYLAND THANK YOU
LIKELY HAVE RESISTED ON THE
BILL TWO. NINE NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. AGAIN JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. HEY. WE TO HAVE A
COMMON LINE OF CAROLINE- BRANDO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAROLYN REGALE BROWN-
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA AND
THEN ON FOR ALL PARENTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THAT. THERE
ARE MANY COMMENTS HERE. RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED SOME HELP
HERE TO STAY PROJECTS. FOR
THIRTY SOME OF THE COMMENTS
HERE SO I APOLOGIZE WE JUST OUR
PURSES TAKING NAMES IS BEING
OVERWHELMED HERE SOME TRYING TO
GET MORE HELP FOR HER THANK YOU.
HELLO YOU GET THE NEXT LINE
HERE I APOLOGIZE YEAH. OKAY
WITH A QUESTION FROM THE LINE
OF MELISSA HAGER. LET ME OPEN
YOUR LINE THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU
DON'T LINE IS NOW OPEN. WHY ARE
AND AYE OPPOSED- AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. JUST ROCK. TO MAKE
IT THE NEXT LINE HERE.
OKAY
WITH YOUR ACCOUNT FOR THE LINE
OF AMY WHILE. MISS WHILE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS AMY
WILDE SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE'RE GETTING
MORE HELP TO GET ALL THESE
COMMENTS HERE I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE STORY HERE.
YEAH WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
IN A AND. HOLIDAYS SHOPPING.
THEY ARE SORT OF GETTING HERE
OR THE PLACE HERE SO MANY
COMMENTS THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO.
GET TO A I APOLOGIZE.
YES WE
HAVE A LOT ACCOUNT FOR LINUS SO
HARD- ERIKA PLEASE GO HEAD.
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA-
I AM A PARENT OF FOR STUDENTS
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL SYSTEM I
AM CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE FELLA. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE LINE OF THIS-
SUSAN. CHANDLER YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN HI. CHANDLER
CALIFORNIA IS. DISABILITY RIGHT
AND WE'D MUCH RATHER GIVE MONEY
TOWARD. FIXING EXCEPT PROBLEM.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR
OUR COME FROM MY END OF
MICHELE- MESA. THANK SHOW ME
THAT CAN TURN HOME COOKED
HEARING IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
THANK YOU.
DIDN'T.
SURE SHE
TOOK A STEP. THE STORE SEVERAL
TO COMMENT HERE I APOLOGIZE.
HEY WE DO HAVE A CARD FOR THE
LINE OF SU LIN VINCENT- YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS
LYNN VINCENT FROM LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA IN LA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI.
THIS IS THE MAIN WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. NUMBER WAY VERSUS.
SISTER YEAH WHAT WE DO THIS WHY
DON'T WE HAVE A WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORT WE'VE HEARD
SOME. SUPPORT ONLINE ALSO SOME
OPPOSITION CLEARLY BECAUSE I
THINK THE CALLS ARE GETTING
MIXED UP BUT THAT'S OKAY SO-
WHAT'S GOOD HERE PEOPLE'S
VOICES IN THEIR PAINS ON THE
BILL SO WHY DON'T WE GO THE TWO
WITNESSES THAT ARE. OPPOSING
THE BILL MAIN WITNESSES IS THE
MAIN WITNESSES- AND ALICE
KESSLER IS I BELIEVE ON THE
PHONE. SO ALICE YOU ARE AND YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR-
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AL CATHARINE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION. YES THEY ARE
TAKING ON OPPOSE IN LAS AMENDED
POSITION ON AB TWO NINE NINE-
SHE CAN'T TAKE KNOWLEDGE IS
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME BAD
PRACTICES WITH RESPECT TO
VENDORS AND IN FACT WE WERE ONE
OF THE EARLY WHISTLE BLOWERS
THAT ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN THE
INDICTMENT OF LEADERS OF THE H.
THREE SCHOOLS. WE HAVE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE THANK
HER FOR THAT WORKING WITH OUR
MEMBERSHIP WE OFFER A FRAMEWORK
TO ENSURE REGRETS AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR VENDOR
QUALITY STUDENT SAFETY AND A
CLEAR CONNECTION OF ACTIVITIES
TO THE STUDENTS WORK PLAN AS
APPROVED BY THE TEACHER. SO
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT
OF THIS BILL AND MANY OF OUR
SUGGESTIONS HAVE BEEN
INCORPORATED WE UNFORTUNATELY
MUST OPPOSE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OVER
PRESCRIPTIVE AND COSTLY AT A
CHALLENGING TIME FOR ALL ELLIE
AIDS WHICH THIS BILL APPLIES
TO. FIRST THE BILL OF THE MEN.
WOULD IMPOSE NEW CONTRACT CODE
REQUIREMENTS THAT NOT ONLY
REACH FAR BEYOND THE BILL
STATED INTENT. WOULD ALSO
VIOLATE THE SPIRIT OF THE
AGREEMENT RECENTLY REACHED ON
CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS IN
EIGHTY FOUR OF SIX FIFTEEN OH
FIVE. AND THAT'S THE ONE TWENTY
SIX PERMITS FROM PREVIOUS
SESSIONS. WE ALSO OPPOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO
AUTHORIZE YOUR APPROVAL OF
TRYING TO GET ALL OF THE-
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF THE MATERIAL REVISION. ORDER
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
OPERATOR CAN NOTICE AND HOLD A
PUBLIC HEARING AND MANDATED
SPOT AUDIT. OPERATORS ALREADY
HAVE BROAD DISCRETION TO REVIEW
POLICIES OF A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND TAKE ACTION INCLUDING
REVOCATION OR NON RENEWAL AT
FISCAL VIOLATIONS ARE NOT
ADDRESSED. YET THEY'VE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
CLARITY IN THE SCOPE IN
TERMINOLOGY OF THE BILL TERMS
LIKE EDUCATIONAL ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITY AND THE PROHIBITION ON
RECEIVING SIR. RIGHT ALL AND
FISCAL INCENTIVES FOR TEACHERS
ARE EITHER TOO BROAD OR TOO
VAGUE EVEN WHERE WE SHARE THE
AUTHOR'S GOAL. FINALLY WE NOTE
THE CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT HOW PUBLIC EDUCATION MAY
BE DELIVERED AND FUNDED MOVING
FORWARD ALL ELLIE AIDS WILL
NEED OPTIMAL FLEXIBILITY TO
OFFER INNOVATIVE SERVICE
DELIVERY MODELS IN THE KOBE
CRISIS. THIS BILL SEEMS TO MOVE
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION FOR THIS
MOMENT THAT WE THEREFORE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR KNOW
ABOUT AN EIGHTY TWENTY NINE
NINETY THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE AND
THEN IS. ERIC PREMAXILLA FROM
THE CHARTER SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT
CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- ERIC BRING BACK
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOL OF
THOUGHT MEANT CENTER WHERE A
TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD.
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SEVERAL HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE- MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS DO MAKE EXTENSIVE
USE OF VENDORS BOTH THE
TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR
SCHOOLS AND TO THE- HOME BASE
SUPPORT SCHOOLS. AND IN. LARGE
PART THERE ARE MANY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN VERY ACCESSIBLE WHEN
TRANSITIONING TO DISTANCE
LEARNING AND THAT'S EMERGENCY
IN PART BECAUSE OF THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH VENDORS- WE
I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME ABUSES IN THIS
AREA. WE THINK THAT THE
COMBINATION OF THE VIGOROUS
PROSECUTION THAT'S ALREADY
GOING ON- PLUS THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AND SEE IF
THEY AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN DOING
THE MEMBERS- ARE STAMPING OUT
NEARLY ALL OF THAT. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL AS
AMENDED IS KIND OF A MASS
FRANKLY IT WOULD SETTLE THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY'RE
CLEARLY NOT- CAPABLE OF SEEING
THROUGH. WE DO SEE SOME MERIT
THEN THE SUGGESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- WE DO
SUPPORT THE NOTION OF HAVING A
PROPER VETTING PROCEDURE. AND
WE ALSO SUPPORT PROHIBITIONS
ON- RELIGIOUS AND SECTARIAN
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS- BUT WE
OPPOSE THE NUMBER OF THE OTHER
SUGGESTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS- FOR EXAMPLE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WOULD
PROHIBIT PROVIDING INCENTIVES
FOR. TEACHERS TO ENROLL IN
RETAIN STUDENTS AND WE THINK IT
CAN BE. ENTIRELY IMPROPRIETIES
IF NOT- VERY HELPFUL TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR TEACHERS WHO ARE
UNUSUALLY SUCCESSFUL. WHEN THEY
DO SO WITH STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE DROP OUT- MIGHT NOT
BE. SIX ALL. AND SO THOSE
ANOTHER REASON WE THAT THE BILL
AND IT'S CURRENT. AND THEN THAT
SUGGESTED AMENDED FORM- IT
SHOULD BE HELD AND- SHOULD NOT
MOVE FORWARD AND THEREFORE WE
ASK FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WITH THAT WHEN WE GO
TO WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY- THE BAIT SHARE YOUR
OPINION IS NOT I. DID NOT TIME
TO TESTIFY AGAIN WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE TOMB IN WITNESSES IN
THIS TOO MANY WE HAVE A RULE WE
HAVE TWO MAIN WITNESSES. THAT
ARE TO BE TEACHERS. SO WE'RE
DOING NOW IS. HER THE ROOM THAT
WAS TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
WITHOUT TOUCHING IT PLEASE-
INJURE SHARE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY ONLY THEY'RE WELCOME
TO DO SO NOW. PLEASE MAINTAIN
DISTANCING IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. RAISE YOUR HAND NOW IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO SEEING NO HANDS
UP WE'LL MOVE ON. GET THEIR
HANDS UP THEN. ALL RIGHT IF I
SAID DO IT BECAUSE WE'RE MOVING
HEY. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
AMY SELLERS I'M A TAXPAYER FROM
EL DORADO COUNTY AND- AT AN
ADVOCATE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU IT'S
UNFAIR LIMITS ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS THANK YOU. HI THERE
HAVE THERE WHEN YOU'RE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. I I'M HERE
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR HOME SCHOOLERS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLERS AND I ALSO
WANT TO PUT YOU ON NOTICE THAT
I DO BELIEVE YOU'RE VIOLATING
THE BROWN ACT BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE NOT ABLE TO GET IN THERE
BEING CUT OFF- IF THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO INTERNET AND
PHONE AND WE HEARD A BILL
EARLIER ABOUT THE ACCESS IN
GENERAL OF POPULATIONS THAT
CAN'T DO THAT AND SO I'M ALSO
ADVISING IT UNDER SECTION
EIGHTEEN TO FORTY ONE AND TWO
FORTY TWO I BELIEVE YOU'RE IN
VIOLATION OF THE BROWN ACT IN
ADDITION TO. IN ADDITION TO
HURTING PEOPLE'S RIGHTS THAT
ARE HER THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU. SHARE YOUR SHARE DO WE
HAVE ANY MORE IN THE ROOM THAT
WISH TO. MY NAME IS CATHERINE
MY PRIDE AND I'M A TEACHER AT
IT WAS CHOI UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT MOTHER OF THREE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER. WE HAVE
ONE MORE. MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRONG. AND AS I INDICATED
EARLIER. I REPRESENT MY
CREDENTIALED PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER HUSBAND. THIS IS MY
COMPUTER I HAVE AT LEAST THIRTY
SEVEN FRIENDS TRYING TO CALL IN
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. THEN YOU CAN A
HEATHER INDICATED AND ARE YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THE
BROWN ACT ARE YOU ARE YOU
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THAT I AM
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED AFFECTED
THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT.
SEEING NO FURTHER TESTIMONY
FROM PERSONS IN OPPOSITION
PERSONS IN THE ROOM WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK TO THE PHONE. AND HEAR
FROM OTHERS ON THE PHONE. SO MR
MODERATE AND USUALLY WHEN
YOU'RE READY SIR WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM A LINE OF HEATHER
MARSHALL YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS HEATHER
MARSHALL AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
FOR SUTTER PEAK CHARTER
ACADEMY. ALIGNED WITH PACIFIC
CHARTER INSTITUTE AND WE OPPOSE
AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
STILL ON THE MONITOR.
TO PICK
OUTLINED SHERIFF HOLIDAYS. THAT
ARE AVAILABLE HERE OKAY SO WE
HAVE- MEGAN ARMSTRONG YOUR LINE
IS ABOUT TO BE OPENED HERE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MEGAN ARMSTRONG
HOMESCHOOLING PARENT FROM
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF POUNDS IN LINE
JANELLE HOLBROOKE. HI CAROLINE.
THANK YOU KNOW HOLDER FROM
CALIFORNIA I AM A- STUDENT ON
ITS AND AYE OPPOSED BUT THEY'LL.
BUT. OKAY TWITTER ACCOUNT FOR
THE LIGHT OF CHRIS TO CANCEL
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI ADAM
MY NAME'S KRISTY CAMPBELL I AM
THE RESIDENT TAXPAYER OF-
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THE BUSINESS OWNER NOT
RELATED TO HOME SCHOOLING IN
ANY CAPACITY AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
COME FROM A LINE OF ROSY IT WAS
I'M NOT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS ROUGHLY A
MONTH FROM WOMAN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M A MOTHER OF FIVE.
GRADUATED HOME FROM SCHOOL FROM
WHAT. AN OLD. I A- SEVERAL KIDS.
ATTENDING TO TROTTERS. THANK
YOUNG BOTH. SB THING NINE NINE.
THANK YOU.
HEY WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT FOR THE
CAROLINE IS THE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS RAVEN BUT AGAIN I'M
HOME MOM AND CAL. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY I HAVE A. TWO NINE
NINE. FOR. HEY WE CAN ACCOUNT
FOR THE LINE AT THE NO LOPEZ
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. A LOOK
AT THAT CALIFORNIA I'M OLD
SCHOOL FATHER PROJECT MANAGER
MIGHT STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
TWENTY NINE NINE. WHICHEVER
COMES FROM A LINE OF DISARRAY
BUTLER YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THAT'S WHERE I'VE BEEN EDUCATOR
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL AB.
TWENTY NINE NINETY. WE TO HAVE
A COMMON FOR THE LINE OF
CRYSTAL JUST BEAR WITH ME HERE.
CRYSTAL HERRERA. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CAPOEIRA AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I'M HOME FROM
A OF TWO CHILDREN AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. TWO NINE
ZERO. THEN WE HAVE A OCEAN
ACCOUNT FROM THE LINE OF.
ARIANNA MONTONEROS YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS ARIANNA
MONTH AND JAZZ I AM A
HOMESCHOOLING TEACHER AN ALLEY
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
BILL AB.
TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
THERE ARE MORE Q. YEP IN WORK.
TRYING TO COLLECT AIRLINE HERE.
OKAY LINE THREE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I THINK THE
MAIN MAN. I WAS INSTRUCTED TO
NOT GIVE DASH FOR NAMES ANY
LONGER OR. SO MANY HERE CUED UP
STILL YET FOR COMMENT. OKAY
THERE'S A CRYSTAL SHREVE WHO
HAS A COMMENT HERE. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THREE ASICS NO
LONGER THERE.
BUT THE MOST YEAH
BUT- YEAH. HOME CAN BE. YEAH BY.
I COME BACK. OFF.
OKAY MY PEARL
SOUTHERN HAVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. WELL HARD I'LL THAT BOARD
OKAY ALL AND I'M HOME SCHOOL AN
I STILL OF THE BILL AB JUNE.
NINE ZERO. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE LINE OF
FOUR ZERO NINE HERE LINE IS NOW
OPEN. SORRY NIGHTLINE AIRPORTS
ARE NOT PLEASE GO AHEAD AND I
APOLOGIZE. FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SANDY
SHAPIRA I'M A TAXPAYER IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF. LINE
FOUR THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE HERE FORTY
SEVEN I DON'T KNOW OPEN FOR
THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE. ONE WELCOME
GOING TO H. I AB TWENTY NINE
NINE. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE TO
HAVE A QUESTION OR COMMENT FOR
THE LINE OF LYING TO. ZERO ONE.
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. DIRE OF
KIDS FROM THAT ARE HOME
SCHOOLED SOME OF THEIR
TRADITIONAL ROLES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AT LINE DROPS
BE CALLED BACK HERE. OKAY LINE.
FOUR HUNDRED TO TEN. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BONNIE HER I AM FROM CLUB AFTER
COUNTY AND A HOME BEEN WITH THE
HOME SCHOOL CHARTER FOR NINE
YEARS WITH FOUR CHILDREN I AM
OPPOSED. TO EIGHTY TWO NINE
NINE ZERO I HAVE BEEN AT YOUR
ALL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
SEAN AND I'M AT. IN PLASTER
OBVIOUSLY CAME BACK. IS FOR
CHILDREN IN FROM SCHOOL. THE
NINE YEARS. AND I ALSO STRONGLY.
AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
AND WE TO HAVE A COMMON FOR THE
LINE OF. FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
FELICIA WOFFORD I AM A
HOMEOWNER A LOT OF PROPERTY TAX
HERE IN LA COUNTY. I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN ONE ON AN I. E. P.
WITH A DISABILITY I HAVE- ONE
CHILD I RECENTLY PUT INTO HOME
SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY. STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AND WE DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE LINE OF
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I BET I BET.
MY NAME IS CHANGING I'M
CALIFORNIA AND I A GREAT WRITER
HOMES GOING IT I CAN NO ON
EIGHT. NINE NINE. THANK YOU CAN
I BUY THEIR COMMENTS AND. MY
NAME IS MIKE BECAUSE I AM FROM
GROVE HELLO AND I AM A IT'S A
GREAT. STARTER HOMES IT I
OPPOSE ABTWO NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. OKAY WE TO HAVE A CO FOR A
LOT OF. FOR HUNDRED TO EIGHT.
HELLO MANY RECURRING DON'T AND
I'M TAXPAYER ALLEY COUNTY. AND
I OPPOSE AB TWO NINE AND. WE
HAVE A COUNT FOR THE LINE A
LINE FOR FIFTY FIVE. THE LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MEGAN MAY I AM ON BOTH CURRENT
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A
COLORFUL LINEUP OF LINE THREE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THIS CALL ME BERMAN FROM
COUNTY CALIFORNIA ONE'S PARENT
OF OVER TEN YEARS AND I OPPOSE
AB. TWO NINE NINE. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM A LINE OF LIGHT TO
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THIS IS TRULY MORE HE FOR.
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED THE
BILL TO. TWO NINE NINE ZERO. IN
ALL ONE THIS IS NOT. AND IT.
THANK HE STARTED. OKAY WE DO A
FOR ALLOW OF TO FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI YES MY
NAME IS HOLLY MERRICK I AM
FROM. SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA
AND I HAVE THREE KIDS WITH
EIGHT CHARTER. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE NINE NOW.
HEY WE DO HAVE A COMMERCIAL
LINE OF LINE THROUGH. NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JULIE ON A
WOULD OCCUR OF BURBANK
CALIFORNIA AND MARKET COUNTY.
AND I OPPOSED.
OKAY WITH A
CALIFORNIA LINE OF LINE FOR
THIRTY FOUR SEVENTY FIVE FOUR
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BRANDY CALDERON I'M
CALLING FROM THE ALTHOUGH
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE- COMMON FOR THE LINE
OF LINE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN. I MEAN FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN. HI YES MY
NAME IS AMY PORTER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I HAVE BEEN A
TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
PUBLIC CLASSROOM BASED AND
INDEPENDENT STUDY BASED CHARTER
SYSTEM FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
PARENT OF FIVE HOME SCHOOLED
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS AND I
PUT BILL. AND WE DO HAVE A
CONFERENCE LINE OF LINE FIVE
HUNDRED SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SECURE FROM KERN
COUNTY WE HAVE THREE CHILDREN
AND A PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE
A- COMMON FOR THE LINE OF. NINE
THREE NINETY SIX. AND HI MY
NAME IS ANDREAS CARRYING ON I'M
AN EDUCATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB
TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU.
HEY. TO I'M GOING TO OUTLINES I
APOLOGIZE SO MAKE SURE THAT SO
AND WE HAVE NOT MISTER. HEY WE
ACCOUNT FOR THE LINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS AHMED DELEGATE I AM
AGAINST THIS BILL. AND MY NAME
IS MARYLAND BILLARD I AM AN
EDUCATOR AND I'VE HAD THREE DUE
TO A BAND BOTH PUBLIC DEBT
EDUCATED AS WELL AS ON BOTH.
AND I'M AGAINST THE BILL. AND
WE ARE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
OKAY IN RETURN OF A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE- OF MARIA SO
PLEASE GO. HI MY NAME IS VERY
AT LEE AND I'M SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY NINE NINE
THANK YOU. OKAY WE TO HAVE A
TELEPHONE LINE OF LINE FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR LOOKING AT TODAY MY
NAME IS CAROLYN SAPP DANIELS
I'M AN EDUCATOR IN ATTACK HERE
FILIPENDULA COUNTY I'M ALSO.
SEVENTY FAMILY FAMILY I. NOT A
BOOK I COULD WITH A BIG OF COME
ALL OR LAW OF PHONE. THE END OF
THE VIAL AROUND THAT WE STRONG
OPPOSE EIGHT JUNE NINE. EVEN IF
IT MEANT THAT THANK YOU. WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A COW FOR THE
LINE OF THE TO HUNDRED SO. SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HELLO
NAME IS A MOLAR BRIGHT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB. TWO NINE
NINE SIX. HELLO. AND MARK. IF
YOU YOU HAVE A IF YOU WISH TO
YOUR PAIN OF BILL DO SO.
THEY'RE STILL SEVERAL TO GIVE
CONCERT WITH HIS CLEANING TO
GET THEIR LINES ASSIGNED HERE
WE HAVE. FIFTY THREE HERE'S THE
MOMENT. BORN YOUR LATEST OPEN
LINE FOR FIFTY THREE I YES
CRISTINA THEM FOR FROM EL
COUNTY MOTHER AT TO HOME SCHOOL.
AND I'M CALLING TO. FAILED TO
AB TWO NINE ZERO TWO NINE NINE
ZERO. AND I'LL CHECK FOR THOSE
WHO CANNOT CALL ARE NOT ABLE
TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH YOUR
ACCOUNT FOR THE LINE OF LINE
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NAME IS SANDY LEWIS
I'M BKER CAL AND COUNTY I AM A
HOME MOTHER OF THREE AND I
OPPOSE EIGHT TWO AND. NINE
ZERO. YOU HAVE A COMMENT FOR
THE LINE OF TWO THREE EIGHT
NINE TWO THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A- AND I AM CALL BY
THE- OKAY. I CURRENTLY HAVE CHU
THE AT A TIME PUBLIC. AND ONE
BEING HOMES. AND I OPPOSE EIGHT
TWO NINE ZERO THANK YOU HAVE A
DAY. WE TO HAVE A TALENT FOR
THE LINE OF TWO ONE. YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YES GOOD AFTER MY
NAME IS LAURIE LEVY I'M A HOME
CHARTERS MOM FROM ALAMEDA. AND
I OPPOSE AB.
TWO NINE NINE.
JUST WAITING FOR LINES TO GET
ASSIGNED HERE LINE FIFTY FOUR
WILL BE UP THE NEXT AND YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER ALL FACTOR I AM A
TEACHER AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF.
FIVE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS THE LAST
ONE LINER AND ANGELES COUNTY
AND I STRONG OPPOSE AB.
TWO
NINE NINE ZERO. HEY WE DO HAVE
A COMMON FOR THE LINE OF TWO
FOUR EIGHT SECURE LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI THIS IS CAROLYN FISHER
A HOME SCHOOL MOTHER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE.
WE DO HAVE A COMMON FROM
THE LINE OF THREE SIXTEEN
AIRLINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ROBERT I AM A HOMEOWNER AND
A RESIDENT SACRAMENTO COUNTY A
GROUP COLOR OR THREE YEARS. AND
I IS STRONGLY OPPOSED AB. TWO
NINE NINE ZERO. HEY WE TELECOM
COMMENT FROM MINE UP TO EIGHTY
ONE HERE IS NOW PLEASE. MY TWO
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANASTASIA DOWN. I AM ANOTHER IF
I CHILDREN THREE GO TO. A
PUBLIC SCOOL AND ARE AND HOW
CARTER I TRY OPPOSE. THE BILL.
ACCORDING TO. OKAY ALIGNED FIVE
FIFTY TO HEAR LINUS DONALDSON
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TERRY HERE ST I'M A
CREDENTIALED RIVERSIDE CAL I TO
STATE YOU GUYS BE MARK AND
HAVING YOUR ME DOWN YOU HAVE A
ON THE BILL. IF WE WERE HERE WE
ARE. AND WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER IT'S. PLEASE JUST YOUR
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
ANYTHING ELSE WILL BE CUT OFF.
OKAY WHATEVER CONTRA LINE OF
LINE TO FIVE THIRTY NINE-
PLEASE. GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARGARET A RAIDER I HAVE
THREE CHILDREN- TO THE PROPOSAL
FOR FIVE YEARS THEY'RE ALL
CURRENTLY IN REGULAR PUBLIC
SCHOOL. I'M CLOSE TO THIS BILL
TWO NINE NINE THREE AB TWO TWO
NINE THE ZERO THEN I HEAR THAT.
OKAY AND WE DO HAVE A CO FROM.
THREE EIGHT TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS ALAN HER MY MAY HOME
SCHOOLING OF THREE AND I AM
OPPOSE TO A. B. TWO NINE NINE
ZERO BUT I HAVE MY WIFE HERE
ALSO. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
HERNANDEZ I AM AS A WITH
CHARTER SCHOOL SYSTEM TEN YEAR
IN THE- COUNTY AREA AND I UP. A.
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
A CALM FOR THE- OF FIVE SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AT YOUR IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHELLE
THEY LONG. I AM A MOTHER FROM
BREAKING UP COUNTY. I AM ALSO A
HOME NUMBER OF TWO ANY. HELLO
BEIJING. THANK THANK YOU. HEY
WE TO HAVE. KEVIN FEDERLINE.
FIVE FIVE EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALLEN YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS NATALIE MORGAN PENNY
LUCY HALE AND THE MOTHER OF TWO
AND A FARMER HOME SCHOOLING
PARENTS AND I OPPOSE AB.
THREE
NINE NINE ZERO. HEY WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FROM LINE FIVE FIVE
THREE. PLEASE CALL OUR- HI MY
NAME IS KAYLA THIS YEAR. AND
I'M CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS THAT
AYE OPPOSED BILL. WITH THE
CURRENT LINE TWO SIX THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I DIDN'T
HURT ME AND WAS AB.
TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. WE TO HAVE A COMMON
FOR THE LINE OF WIND. FIVE FOUR
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. YES THANK YOU
MY NAME IS DIANA FROM JANKO I
AM AN ORANGE COUNTY AND MY
MOTHER FOR AND I'M A HOME
SCHOOLING PARENT AND WE OPPOSE
WE STILL.
WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FOR THE LINE OF LINES FIVE
THREE EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ARE COMING
ALONG AN EDUCATOR AND HOME
PARENT AND BY FAILURE CAL I
OPPOSE A. TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
LINE OR COMING FROM A LINE OF
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THE LAW I AM A RESIDENT
TAXPAYER OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND A PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON. AND I AM OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. I'M GOING
TO REALIZE JUST TO MAKE SURE
NOTHING HAS BEEN COMMITTED HERE.
WE DO HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE
LINE OF. FIVE EIGHTY ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ADDRESS KEREN I AM A TEACHER
AND HOME SCHOOL PARENTS OF
ELEVEN YEARS I'M CARE
CALIFORNIA NINE THOSE AB.
TWENTY NINE NINETY. WE DO HAVE
A COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF. FIVE
HUNDRED NINETEEN. YES GO HEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SABRINA EVEN FIND
A HOME FOR EDUCATOR AND QUALITY
OWNER RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY ROOM
MY. THANK YOU. WE TO HAVE A
COMMENT FOR THE LINE OF. OR TO
NOT. RIGHT. HI MY NAME IS THE
AND BACK ABOUT COUNTY I OPPOSE
THAT. AND THERE ARE NO COME.
OKAY THANK YOU MOVE ON. SKI ME
WE'RE THANK YOU. I'M LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE THAT
WAS A LOT COMMENTS ARE SO YOU
FOR ALL PUBLIC PUBLIC REFER TO
I KNOW THIS IS A PERFECT I KNOW
TOOK A LITTLE BIT AWAY BUT SOME.
DEMOCRACY WERE SO I APPRECIATE
PEOPLE- OF PARTICIPATING IN
THIS PROCESS- SO WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- ANALYST'S
OFFICE HAS COUPLE QUESTIONS. MR
MCCARTY AYE AYE AYE YOU KNOW
WHAT MADE A COMMON MEDICAL I
DON'T REALLY SEE THIS IS- AN
ANTI HOME SCHOOL BILL AT ALL
ACTUALLY I SEE THIS IS A PRO
HOME SCHOOL BILL. BECAUSE OF
I'M SOMEONE WHO SUPPORTS HOME
SCHOOLING I WANTED TO BE.
APPROPRIATE I WANTED TO BE
FUNDED ADEQUATELY I WANT THOSE
DOLLARS TO BE SPENT. TO BE
SPENT ON ON ON THE EDUCATION OF
THE STUDENTS AN APPROPRIATE
PLACE I WANT ACCOUNTABILITY I
WANT OVERSIGHT AND THAT THAT'S
WHAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND I DON'T
THINK I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT MAYBE YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US BUT I DON'T YOUR I
DON'T SEE WAS AND I HOME
SCHOOL. THE AUTHOR IS NOT AND I
HOME SCHOOL DO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT STATEMENT NO I CONCUR
THAT. MISTER. I'M BEING HACKED.
EMAILS THAT. I AM PLACE QUITE.
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND I WAS ADVISED THAT THERE NO
WILL PEOPLE ON WHERE WE FORWARD
I THAT THE- MISTER CHAIR I WAS
GONNA THAT MOST IN. THAT ARE
PART OF THE HOME SCHOOL NEVER
IN CALIFORNIA HER TESTIFYING
HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT
THIS GOES AFTER QUALITY
CONTROLS WITH SOME OF THE BAD
ACTORS AS THE OP THIS IN NOTED
TO. THERE WERE THERE WERE THERE
WERE SOME YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES ARE JUST
OUTRAGEOUS LIKE IN THE ANALYSIS
WHERE PEOPLE GO ONLINE AND
SAYING HEY IF YOU'RE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT SAY YOU CAN USE THIS TO
GET MONIES FOR THINGS LIKE
DISNEYLAND CHICAGO CITY PASS
AND LOCAL AND TICKETS AND SO
THAT. CLEARLY ABUSE OF. PUBLIC
TAX DOLLARS AND MAKING IT BAD
FOR THE HOME SCHOOL FAMILIES
THAT ARE THAT ARE IT RIGHT AND
SO THIS HAS THE NEEDED CLEAN
UPS AND FOCUSING ON SOME
PROCEDURES ALL MAKE SENSE LIKE
KICK BACKS TO. TEACHERS AND
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE-
PROPER- YOU KNOW- GUIDANCE AS
FAR AS HOW TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES. THANK YOU I THINK
YOU WOULD AGREE TO THE
STATEMENT. PUBLIC PUBLIC TAG
PUBLIC SCHOOL DOLLARS A PUBLIC
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS FOR SURE THEY
ALSO MEANT FOR KIDS. AND THEY
SHOULDN'T BE SPENT A SET OF
FAMILY TO CHICAGO FOR THE
WEEKEND TO VISIT A MUSEUM AND
HAVE A GOOD TIME IN CHICAGO YOU
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT. I WOULD
AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE MAYBE
COUPLE THINGS ON THE- THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE- THAT. FIRST
OF ALL I'M NOT THE AUTHOR IS
YOU KNOW BUT I'VE BEEN
COMMUNICATING. WITH HER AND HER
TEAM LITERALLY AS WE SPEAK
HERE. AND THE THERE'S A LOT OF
RESPECT IF THINGS ARE COMING
BACK IN BUT THERE'SNOT THERE'S
SOME DIFFERENCES TIAS THAT I
KNOW THAT THAT THE FIRST OFFICE
IN THE CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION TALKED ABOUT. BEING
OPPOSE A LESS AMENDED. THERE IS
A ONE PIECE IN THERE AS FAR AS-
THE TEACHERS. INCENTIVES THE
OTHER GROUP THE TESTIFIED.
DIDN'T LIKE THAT PIECE AND SO
THERE'S CONFLICTING MESSAGES
FROM SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
GROUPS AND SO I KNOW THE AUTHOR
IS COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THEM AND- TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FOCUS ON THE OVERALL.
GOAL OF THIS IS CLARIFYING
STATE TAX DOLLARS TO PROTECT
THE TAXPAYERS AND STUDENTS. AND
FRANKLY THERE'S PROBABLY GIVE
ME MORE THESE ENTITIES OUT
THERE AND SO IT'S TIME. THAT WE
DO THIS NOW IT'S REALLY- TWO
SIDES OF THE COIN THOUGHT. IN
THE COPA CRISIS SOME MAY SAY
THIS TOO MUCH PAPERWORK GOING
ON RIGHT NOW. IT'S SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY MORE BURDENS ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CHARTERS-
AUTHORIZED I MEMBER CHARTERS
NETWORKS AS FAR AS- HOW TO USE
THESE MONIES BUT ALSO IN THIS
CRISIS THERE IS A NEED TO
PROTECT TAXPAYER DOLLARS. RIGHT
AND THE OTHER HAS WORKED. AS
SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION WORKING ON
THIS BILL IN FACT THEY'VE
CHANGED IN HELP. MODIFY THIS
BILL INTO FASHION MORE TO THEIR
LIKING THAT ON IN SUPPORT TODAY
BUT EVEN THEY ALLUDED TO THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE PROBLEMS.
HOW HOME SCHOOL. SOME HOST
SOMEONE ONCE A SENSE IT'S NOT
ALL LET'S BE CLEAR SOME HOMES
TO ORGANIZATIONS ARE SPENDING
THEIR MONEY SO THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN
INVOLVED AND CONTINUES TO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS- AS I
UNDERSTAND IS THAT A FACT.
CORRECT CORRECT AND AS I NOTED
THERE IS ONE PROVISION THAT
AMENDMENT THAT THEY TOOK IN
THERE. RELATED TO INCENTIVES
GOING TO TEACHERS WHICH WAS
THAT THE SUGGESTION. OF THE
ASSOCIATION AND THAT. PROVISION
IN THERE IS NOW OPPOSED BY WHAT
THE OTHER GROUPS OPPOSING HE
BILL SO. SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO.
SET TO SORT THIS OUT WITH AND-
I THINK THE SHE STATED THAT SHE
IS COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THEM AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS. AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
LISTEN I'M A CLASSROOM TEACHER
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT I AS A
TEACHER WOULD GET MONEY. FROM A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR AN OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATION TO RECRUIT
STUDENTS. INTO SOME OUTSIDE
ACTIVITY I THINK THAT WOULD BE
PRETTY NEFARIOUS WRONG AND-
SETS UP A LOT OF BAD THINGS
COULD COME OUT OF THAT. CORRECT
ME IN I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE
THAT IF THERE IS A VENDOR IN
THE AFTER SCHOOL OVER THERE
NEED TO BE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY. THESE FOLKS
MIGHT EVEN NEED TO BE
BACKGROUND CHECK BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS SENDING KIDS OFF
TO MAYBE HORSEBACK RIDING
LESSONS ETCETERA. HEY AND SOME
THESE OPERATORS NIGHT MIGHT NOT
EVEN HAVE BACKGROUND CHECKS SO
I THINK I THINK WE NEED IT THAT
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE HAD
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT AND BOB IN ESSENCE
SHOULDN'T BE PAID TO SEND THEIR
KID TO A CERTAIN SCHOOL I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S IN SOME INSTANCES
WHAT DOES BEEN ALLUDED TO IF
YOU ARE GETTING A MATERIAL GOD
TO SEND THEIR CHILD TO A
CERTAIN INSTITUTION AND THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
WITH PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS AND
AGAIN I I'D I'D MAYBE I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR ANYONE HERE BUT I
DON'T THE ANYONE'S NECESSARILY
AGAINST HOME SCHOOL RIGHT HEY
IT'S HAPPENING EVERYWHERE ALL
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW- IT WE'RE ALL RIGHT YOU'RE
ALL HOME SCHOOLERS TODAY RIGHT
I'VE GOT TO- AND HEY MIGHT HOME
SCHOOLING BE AN OPTION FOR ME
THE FUTURE IT MIGHT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME I WANT. THESE GOOD
GOVERNMENT PRACTICES IN PLACE
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC TAX
DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT THESEEFFORTS BUT ALSO
TO PROTECT THE CHILDREN SO THAT
THAT THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE I
BRING- IS SO WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WISH
TO ASK QUESTIONS TO KIND. MR TO
THERE ARE STILL A CUP. WHO TO
LIKE. BECOME A IPOD I DID SEE
THEIR AT THE BASED HERE. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO MISTER COLIN GOT
THOSE IN JUST A MINUTE GOING.
KIND OF. WHAT WE THINK GIVE TO
SOMEONE WANT TO COME. I AM.
HEARING OR NOT YOU. OKAY NOW
JERRY HERE MISTER. OKAY DID
ANYONE ELSE WANT TO COME RIGHT
NOW. FROM IT BUT I BEEN WITH.
AND I READ THIS THE PRIME THAT
GIVE THEM SOME OF THIS OF THE
FACT OF WHATEVER THE LAW WE'RE
TO HAVE. IN. RIGHT I GUESS
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS
IS IT TOOK ME INFO ME AS WE IT
IT TOOK ME SO MANY DIRECTIONS
AND WHAT I CAN DO THAT READING
IT NOT ONLY ONE. FIVE THREE
SEVEN COULDN'T FIGURE WERE WELL.
I MEAN I DIDN'T KNOW IF THE OF.
SEE IT IN ITS SIMPLEST FORM.
THEN I HAVE A THOUSAND
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT DOES IT
RELATE TO THESE FOLKS VERSES
THESE FOLKS VERSES THIS
EXPERIENCE FOR THAT EXPERIENCE
AND WHERE DOES IT TAKE ME IN
THE IN. AND SO I JUST HAD SOME
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE THE
BILL WAS READY YET AND THEN
IT'S JUST ME THINKING THAT THAT
THEY WERE THERE WITH THAT
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME.
ISSUES HERE. BUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T CLARIFIED STRONGLY
ENOUGH SO THAT IT GIVES PEOPLE
SOME. SINCE THE IT'S GOING TO
FOCUS ON THIS AND SOLVE PROBLEM
FOR US OR THE GOING TO CREATE
MORE PROBLEMS BECAUSE IT'S SO
BROUGHT IN ITS NOT CLEARLY
DEFINE WELL ENOUGH TO REALLY
GET TO THE PROBLEM AND I FELT
LIKE IT WAS IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM AND SO. I JUST HAD SOME
AND I AND I GUESS THAT I READ
IT ONCE ABOUT MAYBE I WAS TIRED
SO I. PUT IT DOWN READ IT LATER
ON IF HOURS. AND THEY WILL UP
THIS MORNING AND READ IT AGAIN.
AND SO I. HAVE I JUST I JUST
WANT. THE MAYBE YOU CAN CLARIFY
IT BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S A DID
SPEAK THE OFFICE. AND ASKED A
NUMBER. AS IT APPLIES ALL TO IN
THE TO EL EVERY DESTROY AT THE
JUST TO TRY. HOME SCHOOLING AND
LIKE TO. AND THEN. THEN THE
QUESTION BE OKAY WILL THAT HOW
WE- THE SIX. OR WHATEVER AND A
AND IT MAY I DON'T IT'S WORTH
THING IN THE WORLD HIS GO
DISNEYLAND MAYBE AT THE BECAUSE
SEEN THEM A CITY. WERE HAVING
CERTAIN XP. WERE CREEK. OF WHAT
I WAS A KID IN THE PRIDE WE HAD
A LOT OF EXTRA. THAT WE NEVER
WOULD GOTTEN OTHER. IN AND SOME
OF WHICH RELATE TO OUR CREW. IT
WAS A EDUCATE WE WANT TO THE I.
AND THIS IN THIS IS ALSO A OF.
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE.
WHERE DOES THIS BILL LEE. ME AN
AND WE'LL IT. MORE BY LIMIT.
FOLK WHO ARE. OF WHO WANT TO DO
THINGS IN SCHOOL. AND MAYBE
IT'S- ON THE- LIVE. OF BIG. ALL
OF US. YOU KNOW THEY'VE GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO SO. THAT
CAN'T. AND A BECAUSE AND I
DON'T LIST. YOU KNOW SO I DON'T
REALLY SURE WHO. WE'RE THIS
TAKES ME MAYBE. CAN CALL. FOR
ME. RIGHT AFTER. ON IT DANI A
BIG PROBLEM IS AND WHY OR NOT
THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE IT AND
NEED. WHO I TALKING TO. GO BOOK.
RIGHT NOW THIS IN YOUR BILL
ANYWAY I'LL SO I JUST I'M THINK
THAT'S BEING A PART OF ME OKAY
CHRISTY BUT ANYWAY SO JUST
TRYING TO OUT. WHAT THE
LIMITATIONS OF FOR THE TACTIC
BILL SO THAT IT BECOME THIS WHO.
SAYING THAT WE HAVE TO. YOU
KNOW EVERY TIME WE TURN AND
WE'RE ADDING RESTRICTIVE
RESTRICTING SOME TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE NOT. THIS IS THIS
IS GOING SOLVE PROBLEM ENOUGH
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS THAN WHAT THE NOT IT'S
READY FOR PRIMETIME I MEAN
THAT'S MY CONCERN MY BIG
CONCERN. OKAY THANK YOU I THINK
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE. GOOD
RELEVANT QUESTIONS I THINK THE
OTHER WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S TO
CONVERSE GOING ON I DON'T TO
SPEAK FOR THE AUTHOR I YOU'RE
SPEAK FOR THE OFFICE THAT YEAH
PART BUT MISSED CHAIR I. TO
DOCTOR WEB IS CA. THAT A FEW
QUESTIONS IF THE MAIN ONE THAT
THAT I THINK THAT. I CAN ANSWER
RIGHT NOW IS TO DO THIS. TO
VISIT PICK AND CHOOSE. WHO WERE
SO. CALLED GOING AFTER A NOW
IT'S NOT JUST. CHARTERS IT'S
ANY. ANTI AND CAL. PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. THAT HAS THESE
EDUCATION RICHMAN ACTIVITIES TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE- ACADEMICALLY
APPROPRIATE- AND HAVE- PURSUANT
OVERSIGHT. WITH THE BODY THAT
THAT GOVERNS THAT SCHOOL THAT
THAT SCHOOL OR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AFTER THIS. RIGHT YOUR HAVE A-
THIS REGARDING MISTER KRAMER
WITH THEM. AT THINGS GOING ON
HERE ONCE MISTER KAY. NOW I'M
GOING TO BE COUNTY. AND I WILL
NOT DIE ANY THEY THE OFF I HIS
NOT HERE AB DOT I WANT TO THANK
I'D WANT TO STAY THE TIME OUT
TO IN AND MAKE YOUR VOICE FOR
UNDER THE AND YOU CERTAIN. I
WILL SAY I MEAN YOU LOOK AT
THIS BILL AND YOU REALLY HAVE
TO SHAKE YOUR HEAD HI THERE ARE
YOU KNOW A FEW OF SCOURING THE
WHOLE STATE WE FOUND A FEW
ALLEGEDLY INAPPROPRIATE-
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES THAT TOOK
PLACE AND THEN THAT IS USED AS
A PRETTY STACKS TO WIPE OUT A
BACK ARRAY. OF AN MARKET IS ALL
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
DON'T THINK ABOUT BILL SALINAS
IT MEANS. WORK THE STATE. I OUR
EFFORTS GO ON TO. INSTILL IN
KIDS LOVE OF LEARNING USING
CREATIVITY INNOVATING GETTING
THEM EXCITED ABOUT DIFFERENT
CAREER PATHS AND NONE OF THAT
WILL BE POSSIBLE UNDER THIS
BILL UNLESS YOU FIRST GET PRE
APPROVAL FROM A BUREAUCRACY ON
A FEVER LIST OF VENDORS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. THAT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING AS WE LOOK OUT AT A
CHANGING ECONOMY MR CURRENTLY
BECOMING MEMORIES OF IT. WE CAN
AREA OKAY WAS SUBMITTED ON A
JUST CALM DOWN AND POINT IT IS
A POINT JUST PLEASE JUST PLEASE.
IT'S ALSO I'M NOT FORGET THE
THIS BILL. MAKES IT. IN FACT IT
I PROHIBITS FINANCIAL FOR OUR-
WHO MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD. TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES. SO IT'S ALSO AN
ISSUE OF EQUITY AS WELL SO I
YOU KNOW THAT THIS BILL TAKE
THIS IN EXACTLY THE WRONG
DIRECTION. AND I'D VERY MUCH
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE ON THIS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE VOICES
THAT ARE COMING THROUGH US-
TELEPHONICALLY HERE AND A FEW
FOLKS WHO ARE. HERE IN PERSON
AS WELL AND LET'S NOT PUT THIS
PUSH THIS BILL FORWARD. THANK
YOU THINK YOUR COMMENTS. ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING AND WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A RECESS FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES FIVE MINUTES. NO MORE
THAN FIVE AND WHAT BACK. IN A
FIVE MINUTE SO THIS COMMITTEE
WILL STAND IN RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES FROM NOW.
BATTERY BACK.
OKAY. OKAY THEY ARE WE GOING TO
RECONVENE THE- EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HEARING AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONES RIGHT
NOW. BACK TO THE PHONES. UP SO
MODERATOR WHEN YOU ARE READY-
WE ARE READY TO LISTEN AND
AGAIN IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE-
PLEASE ONLY STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU'RE FULLY
WITH AGREEMENT OFFICE OKAY FOR
NOT- IN POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY ANYMORE YOU WILL BE. CUT
OFF THANK YOU.
MR MCCARTY I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY. OTHER
SOME DISCUSSIONS AND AMENDMENTS
EARLIER AND- SO THIS BILL DOES
NOT ELIMINATE EDUCATIONAL RICH
IN RICHMOND OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL THEY ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
HOME SCHOOL EVEN THE REGULAR
SCHOOL BECAUSE MEMBERS OF THE
TO BUT IT'S A BLANKET BILL.
PLACE TO ALL LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES IN. ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- SO DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THOSE OUTSIDE
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES JUST
REQUIRES AN BEGIN APPROVAL NO
LONGER WILL BE DONE BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION BUT AT THE LOW. BOTH
LOCAL CHARTER SCHOOL OR LEN.-YES CORRECT WE ACCEPTED THE YES
YES.
THANK YOU. TELL YOU ANY
CANDY. YEAH KILEY ON CANDY CAN.
I DON'T THAT CAN GET THE MYTH.
RIGHT NOW. NO LONGER HAVE YOUNG
CHILDREN.
RIGHT.
I THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
TAKE A THIRTY MINUTE RECESS A
THIRTY MINUTE RECESS WHILE THEY
WORK ON SOME TECHNOLOGY ISSUES
INSIDE THE BUILDING THANK YOU.
MIKE AT.
YOU'LL ALSO HEAR WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING.
OKAY WELL THANK
YOU FOR A- AWAITING THE END OF
OUR RECESSES- WILL CALL THE. I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU FOR
AWAITING THE END OF OUR RECESS
I AM CALLING THE- ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONES AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM CALLERS AS THEY CALL IN
AND- THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO- TO- MAKE ABOUT
MAYBE HEARD IT A HUNDRED TIMES
FAR AND I. I'VE GOT A TWO NINE
NINE ZERO EIGHT TWO NINE ZERO
OR THAT BILL NOW WE'RE IS GO
BACK TO PHONES OF PEOPLE WAY
THERE TO HEAR US TO BE SURE.
THANK YOU THAT GO BACK ON MY
PLATE. NINE TWO FIFTY THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIRTY WILL
APPEAR. MY NAME IS NOT ON I
ALWAYS. NINE NINE YEAH MY NAME
IS LISA MARIE CONGRESS COUNTY I
WILL WORK YEARS AGO AS A HOME
SCHOOL AND THEN AT. AND I. WE
HAVE A LINE THREE TO SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE HODGES I
AM AN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
MOM OF THREE HOME SCHOOLERS AND
ALSO A TEACHER AT A LOCAL
QALAT. I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TWENTY SIX FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS JOSH WHAT
SURE YOU CAN'T WALKING COUNTY
FATHER OF FOUR. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSES. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE. HI MY NAME
IS MAY I AM AND HOW TO CUT THE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA HEY MAY
HOMESCHOOLING MOM I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN AND TAXPAYERS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. NINE SIX NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DR I
LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. I'M A FORMER PUBLIC
EDUCATOR AND HOME SCHOOLER TO
TURNOUT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO. THE LORD
FOR THE NEXT FIVE. BUT THE.
NINE NINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH. THE. BILL IN THE-RIGHT. SACRAMENTO COUNTY THANK
YOU ALL THREE LETTERS FOR. DOWN
I AM ALSO AND COLD AND I OF AB
NINE ZERO FIVE MAY HAVE HERE.
ALL RIGHT BOB. IT WAS WITH
STROM. I NINE THANK YOU YOU
JUST ONE PERSON PER CALL PLEASE.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY UNLESS I I'M GOING
TO HIGH SCHOOL I LIVE IN IRVINE
AND ME AND MY MOM BOTH STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
TIME SURE.
OKAY LINE SEVEN FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THERE COUNTY
AND. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE
WINE NINE HUNDRED NINETEEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MINOR REAGAN.
UNDER REAGAN FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE NINE NINE ZERO. OKAY
WE HAVE A LINE FRONT CONTRABAND
TWENTY HERE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THE HEART OF
CALIFORNIA I AM A HOME SCHOOL
MOM OF BY TRIGGERED AN
EXTREMELY PUT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE A COVER FROM LINE
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOING TO RELEASE.
THE
SCREEN IS BETTER IS SPONSORING
A ME I APOLOGIZE.
HEY WE DO
HAVE A COLD COMING FROM NINE
EIGHT FORTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ONE ITEM
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE WILL
HOME SCHOOL FAMILY FOR YEAR AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
WOULD BE. TWO NINE NINE ZERO.
OKAY WE ARE CALLING FROM NINE
EIGHT FIFTY SIX- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS TWENTY
I GET IT AND I AM A MOM OF
THREE HOME. CONTRA CALL
CALIFORNIA. AT THE COUNTY
.
EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO. WITH THE
COMING FROM LINE EIGHT TWO ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I HAVE A
QUESTION BEFORE I MAKE MY
STATEMENT THAT WHEN YOU LEARN
RECESS ACCORDING TO THE
OPERATOR THERE WILL BE PEOPLE
THAT WERE IN THE IN THE YOU'LL
TO MAKE COMMENTS WHY ARE COMMON
IN THE NIGHT BY YOUR DECISION
WHY CAN'T MAKE ANY. COMMENTS. I
HELLO SIR THIS IS A- KEVIN
KILEY- THE CHAIR PATRICK
O'DONNELL STEP ROOM- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S BEEN SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES- WITH
THAT- THE VENDOR THAT'S BEING
USED HERE AND THAT WE AND THE
BABY IS LYING- THE NEVER HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO MAKE YOUR
PUBLIC. AND WITH THAT. AS
REGION. WE GOT STARTED SO THAT
THERE STILL ONLY THIRTY WERE
MAKING COMMENTS AS IT MAKES NO
SENSE FOR YOU THE NATURAL.
TWENTY NINE NINETY SEVEN AYE
OPPOSED THE WAY THAT YOU'RE
HANDLING THIS. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
SIR LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CAR.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A TALENT
FOR THE LINE- FLYING NINE
HUNDRED EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE MILLION MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH AND I'M NOT I'M
CAMANCHE COUNTY CALIFORNIA I'D
BE HOME COOKING FOR THE LAST
SIX YEARS I HAVE TWO KIDS IN
AYE OPPOSED. TWENTY NINE NINETY
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS MARK ALSO
ALMOST I AM THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
AND I'M HAPPY IN MY CHARTER
SCHOOL I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY NINE NINETY THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE A CUT FROM THE
LINE OF SEVEN EIGHTY. NINE I
DON'T REALLY. I SERVICE
WRAPPING. OKAY WITH THE ACCOUNT
FOR THE LINE OF EIGHT ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER HERNANDEZ CALLING FOR
OUR MEMBERS. COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
AB YOU CAN RECOGNIZE THAT. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR A COMIC FOR THE
LINE OF EIGHT SIX THREE YOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MICHELLE THE BEING OUT FRONT
NEVER DID YOU KNOW COUNTY I AM
CREDENTIALED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M A LICENSE.
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST WHO WORKS
WITH CHILDREN WITH DOCTOR. AND
I AM CALLING TO OPPOSE- AB.
THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE A
COMMENT TO FRONTLINE OF EIGHT
SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS RYAN FROM ONLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THE COMMENT FROM THE
LINE. NINE FOUR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOE OUT OF
THE BOX AND THE PROFESSOR AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND SACRAMENTO AND VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE FUTURE OF
EDUCATION IN STATE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR- OFFICIALS.
PARLIAMENT THANK YOU. CAN YOU
KNOW THE BILL WE OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK AYE VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE YOU. MISTER OKAY
WE DO HAVE COMMENT THE LAW OF.
NINE NINE FOUR SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
WENT TO PARK IN THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE I'M A FORMER CLASS
AND TEACH CURRENTLY HOMES WILL
TAKE THE THREE. IN THE NAY
BUDGET CHOICE BROADLY OPPOSED.
EIGHT EIGHT TWO NINE NINE. OKAY
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMON FOR THE
LINE UP NINE. FOUR SEVEN. HEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS MELANIE WELSH
FROM ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I AM
A FOUR POINT OH GPA COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHOSE HOMES FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB EIGHT TWO NINE ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR KILEY.
WE DO HAVE A COUNT FROM LINE
NINE FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE NINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT WOULD HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE NINE FIFTY ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I. DURING MY CLASSES MY
CHARTER ARE HAS A GOOD JOB
AFTER AND HI MY MOM. YOUR THANK
YOU WOULD YOU OPPOSED BILL YOUR
PA THE BILL NOT. TO MEET YOUR-
AB TWENTY THANK YOU GOOD JOB.
OKAY LEAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
NINE FIFTH TWO. HELLO MY IS
JENNIFER FACTOR I AM AN
EDUCATOR AND A HOME SCHOOL MOM
OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSED AB.
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. HEY WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE NINE
SIX THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
MY NAME IS REBECCA DEVINE
OUTSIDE OF DAVIS CALIFORNIA
YOLO COUNTY- HOMESCHOOL MOM OF
FIVE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY TWO NINE NINE ZERO THANK
YOU. HEY WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE- NINE FIVE SEVEN. HI
MY NAME IS JESSICA MOST THAT I
LIVE IN MENIFEE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWO
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU. HEY
WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM NINE
NINE SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY BACKGROUND I'M A CHARTER
SCHOOL MOM AND UNCLE PARENTS
AND I UP CLOSE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
COUNT FOR THE LINE OF NINE
SIXTY SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
MNICA BAR I AM AN ATTORNEY AND
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND OFTENTIMES
GOING MOTHER OF TWO AND I
OPPOSE AB. TWO NINE NINE ZERO
THANK YOU FOR THE REST.
WE HAVE
A QUESTION OR A KIND OF A LINE
OF NINE SIXTY NINE. GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS LAURA CATHY I'M
CALLING FROM EL DORADO HILLS IN
EL DORADO COUNTY AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. TWENTY NINE
NINETY THANK YOU. LEAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE NINE SEVENTY
FIVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS REBECCA GARTON FROM SHOCK
COUNTY. I'M A FORMER- CLASSROOM
TEACHER AND I CURRENTLY HOME
FOR MY OWN FOUR CHILDREN AT THE
WRONG WE OPPOSE AB RIGHT NOT
ZERO. HELLO. NUMBER HELLO THEY
DIDN'T GET THERE IF YOU MAKE A
COMMENT I AM RELEASING YOU
THANK YOU. YOU HAVE A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE UP FOR THE SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RELEASING AT THIS
POINT. OKAY LEAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE NINE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE IS GONNA BE
COMMENDED COMMENDED COMMENDED
COMMENDED COMMENDED GO. AHEAD
AND.
HEYWE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
NINE NINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
RAFAEL AFFECT VIA I AM A HOME
SCHOOL PARENTS AND COOPER
EDUCATOR LOCATED IN BENICIA
CALIFORNIA SOLANO COUNTY AND
AYE OPPOSED AB TWO NINE NINE
ZERO. THANK YOU. WE ARE COMING
FROM NINE NINE NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TRUTH IN COOKING I'M A HIGH
SCHOOL A HOMESCHOOL FATHER OF
PPA A TAX RETURN VOTER AND MARK
STONE AND STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. WE HAVE A
TALENT FOR THE LINE NINE NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS AMBER STANDARDS AND I
LIVE IN LA COUNTY AND THE LIFE
OF A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE THERE. WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE ONE THOUSAND PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME ON
COURTESY RATHER THAN ORANGE
COUNTY I'M A PAIR OF. HI
MICHAEL NOT THAT I'M THE
CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THAT EIGHTY
NINE NINE. WE HAVE A COMMON
FROM LINE ONE THOUSAND AND
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT HI
MY NAME IS BOBBY FROM KERN
COUNTY I. EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO
AND W'RE WITH PARENTS FOR
PARENTS COOLEY. OKAYBUT FOR
THE LINE OF ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. READING MY
NAME IS DOCTOR TO MAKE SHOULD
ENTER GEMMA RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AND I
RESEARCH THE EFFECTS OF THE
QUALITIES ON THE HEALTH OF MATH.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT UNITS
ALSO NEED TO DO IS STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY PLEASE SO WITH
THAT WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER.
IT WILL HAVE A COMMENT
FROM THE LINE OF ONE. THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN. IT COULD HAVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDICAL
RELEASE ON. WE HAVE A COMMENT
FOR A LINE OF. ONE THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KELLY WEBSTER AND I AM A HOME
SCHOOLING CHARTER PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OF THE OPPOSE AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY. WE HAVE A
COMMON FOR THE LINE OF ONE
THOUSAND THIRTY ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SO. RIGHT AND WITH OTHER
COURT ACTION RIGHT. AND WE
MIGHT. NOT. AS WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF. ONE
THOUSAND THIRTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS EVELYN
BULLARD SAID THEN ABOUT VOCAL
CHARTER PARENTS- THREE CHILDREN
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF
ONE THOUSAND AND FORTY TWO. HI
MY NAME IS JENNIFER HI MY NAME
IS JENNIFER LAMB I'M A HOME
SCHOOLER CHARTER MOM FROM
TEMECULA I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. WE DO HAVE
A COMMA FOR THE LIFE OF FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DANIELLE
NICOLE OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M
GOING MOTHER WERE NEARLY TEN
YEARS I STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY
NINE NINE ZERO THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF
ONE THOUSAND FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
SHAPE- I LIVE IN COURT GOLD IN
THE COUNTY OF MADERA AND AS A
HOME SCHOOLING CHARTER GOING
MOM I ALSO OPPOSE. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY THANK YOU. LEAVE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
BUNKER ALL GROW I'M A FORMER
EDUCATOR I HAVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN EDUCATION AND I'M A
MOTHER OF ONE AND A FUTURE HOME
SCHOOLER DUE TO SB TWO SEVENTY
SIX AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHT
TWO NINE NINE ZERO. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A COMMERCIAL LINE OF
ONE THOUSAND FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GEORGE JACOBSEN AND
ARE BUCKLING COLUSA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN HOME
EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN FOR OVER
TEN YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO NINE
NINE ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
FOR THE LINE OF ONE THOUSAND
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO EXTENSIVE FISHER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M
HOMESCHOOLING CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS THANK YOUNG WE OPPOSE
AB TWO NINE NINE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A COMMON FOR THE LINE OF
ONE THOUSAND FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE THOUSAND FIFTY
NOT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW
MANY OF THE QUIRK STRICKER FOR
MARIN COUNTY CALIFORNIA I AM AN
EDUCATOR STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO. DID YOU
HEAR THAT. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
NEXT FIND A AND- THE NEXT LINE
IS WITH. THE DISK VERIFY HERE
BECAUSE.
ONE THOUSAND SIXTY
SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DAVID
BAILEY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED.
TO EIGHTY NINE NINE ZERO OKAY
GREEN MY HOME ONLINE. WHEN I
VERIFIED IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
LINES PLEASE ALLOW ME A MOMENT
SO THAT NO ONE IS OMITTED.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE COULD
AFFORD. I'M SORRY THERE WAS
WAITING FOR HIM TO VERIFY. WELL
THERE IS NO WAY YOU CAN. YEAH
WE'RE NOT WE'RE DONE PUBLIC
KNOW THAT IN MY LIFE. THAT. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD. RIGHT LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY FURTHER COMMENT MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SINGLE FOR
THE COMING FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER MCCARTY YOU MAY
CLOSE. YEAH I THINK YOU. FOR
THE PATIENTS EVERYBODY- YOU
KNOW THIS IS AN EMOTIONAL TOPIC
I THINK IT IF WE BELIEVE WHAT
THE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE SAT ON
THE CALL WE WOULD BE PROPOSING
THIS BILL THIS IS REALLY A NEW
COMMENTS PROPOSAL HERE WE'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE AWAY HOME SCHOOL
ON SCHOOL CHARTER SCHOOL
OPTIONS WERE GONNA. PUT A FEW
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AND IS TO PROTECT THE TAXPAYERS
TO PROTECT THE STUDENTS BECAUSE
MORE AND MORE FAMILY GONNA TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF HOME SCHOOLING SO
I WILL ASK YOU RIDE THE THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
CLARIFICATION THAT YOU MADE IN
YOUR CLOTHES THAT THIS. APPLIES
TO ALL SCHOOLS. NOT SHUT DOWN
ANY SCHOOL IS NOT A RIFLE AIMED
AT CHARTER AT CHARTER SCHOOLS
IS NOT A RIFLE AIMED AT HOME
SCHOOLS IT'S JUST A BLANK A
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND STUDENT SAFETY SO
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THAT POINT
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE
SECRETARY- IF. YEAH. I DO I AM
I AM GOING TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT HERE QUICKLY SEE
IF INDIVIDUALS WAS TO FURTHER
COMMENT. OR OR OR OR HAVEN'T
AND DID NOT GET TO COMMENT
TODAY. WE WANT TO I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WE EXPERIENCED
TODAY WITH OUR PHONE SERVICE
DUE TO THE PERSISTENCE. OF
THESE AND EXPECTED ISSUES WE'LL
BE ACCEPTING EMAIL PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THIS HEARING SO YOU
CAN STILL COMMENT FOR THIS
HEARING. AND I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
THE EMAIL ADDRESS IN JUST A
MOMENT AGAIN IF YOU TO COMMENT
FOR THIS HEARING. BECAUSE YOU
DID NOT GET A CHANCE HERE IS AN
EMAIL ADDRESS FOR YOU TO SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS. YOU CAN SUBMIT
THESE COMMENTS TO THIS ADDRESS-
EIGHTY E. D. N. COMMITTEE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOP I'M
GONNA DO THAT AGAIN READ THAT
AGAIN. OKAY SO IT'S A AS AN
ADAM E. ISN'T EDWARD D. ISN'T
DAVID AND AS A NOR. DOT
COMMITTEE AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOP. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
ADDRESS ON THE EDUCATION THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. YEARS AGO THAT WEBSITE
THAT ADDRESS WILL BE ON THERE
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS ON
THIS BILL. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR UNDERSTANDING AND PATIENCE
AS WE DEVELOP THESE PRACTICES
WHICH ARE ALL NEW TO US. AND
SOMETHING HOPEFULLY WON'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH FOR TOO LONG THE
RIGHT NOW WE CERTAINLY DO. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THE FOLKS AROUND ME AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND THE PROCESS
SO WITH THAT I TURNED OVER THE
TO THE SECTOR. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. O'DONNELL AYE.
O'DONNELL I HIGHLY DOUBT. KILEY
NUMBER DALLY. NO VALLEY NOW
KALRA. KALRA I'M A PARTY HI
PARTY ICE MISS. SMITH I WEBER.
SO HAVE. THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTED IS OUT MISTER MCCARTY AND
MISTER. CERTAINLY THE ROLE OF A
FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T VOTE ON
ITEMS THAT WERE HERE EARLIER.
IF YOU WISH SO. YEAH SO I CAN
CALL THE ROLL OF. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR KILEY KILEY
I'D- AND. THAT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES IF
WE FIND OUT OF DOCTOR WEBER IS
COMING AN OLDER MAN OPEN IF WE
FIND OUT SHE'S NOT THAT. GAVEL
DOWN. THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED. OTHER OFFICE OF.